so last night we were watching the town
hall with Donald Trump here on timcast
IRL and I don't know if you noticed but
when they wrapped the show up I was like
I I guess the show's over because we had
planned for the show to go till 9 30.
and we noticed a couple things there
were weird commercials back to back they
did no commercials and all of a sudden
went to commercial then came back for
like 10 minutes and then went to
commercial again and then abruptly shut
the show down it is confirmed that CNN
cut the show short by 20 minutes and we
don't know why but I think it's because
Donald Trump was roasting them on their
own network everyone was cheering and
they panicked so we're gonna we're gonna
talk about the ramifications of this
we've got CNN employees are in Revolt
all of the liberal left are screaming
how dare you CNN and I think CNN is now
bleeding what little audience it had
left Jeff Zucker turned the network from
generic corporate news into leftist
psychopathy and now those people are
Furious and Chris liked new CEO he's not
going to be able to bring that back
sorry you can't you can't resurrect this
corpse then we got other big news
Daniel Penny the man in New York who was
defending people from a violent deranged
man who then tried to save that man will
be criminally charged so thanks to the
likes of people like AOC in the far left
they're getting what they want and this
man who was trying to save others and
the violent perpetrator himself
yeah he's going to get locked up he's
getting manslaughter charges which I
imagine he'll likely I mean maybe he'll
plea take a plea maybe he'll get
convicted I think he's going to do some
kind of time so we'll talk about that
plus Elon Musk has appointed a new CEO
or has announced a new CEO of Twitter
coming soon and uh we think we know who
it is the Wall Street Journal has the
report before we get started my friends
head over to castbrew.com and purchase
cast Brew Coffee we have just launched
the cast Brew Coffee Club where for 40
bucks you get three different roasts per
month and that's actually a pretty good
deal because normally it would be like
46 to 50 bucks so it's a big discount
and we haven't we're we have to update
it but there's gonna be a discount
system where after a certain amount of
time like six months the price drops
even further for our long-standing
customers and the other news
unfortunately ladies and gentlemen we've
sold out of rise with Roberto Jr so
thank you guys so much for supporting
Casper coffee that just basically means
we sold a lot of coffee yeah we sold out
and uh and then some so we're we're
roasting the next batch for everybody go
to casper.com if you want to support the
show be because we are sponsoring
ourselves in light of everything that's
happening in this in this world we got
another story too pertaining to Jeremy's
chocolate a gay conservative Professor
was put on leave for just having the
chocolate available for people to eat
that's it so we're going to talk about
the parallel economy too don't forget to
also head over to timcast.com click that
join us button in the menu bar sign up
to become a member and you can hang out
in our Discord server with like-minded
individuals and submit questions for our
members only uncensored show Monday
through Thursday at 10 10 p.m we're
gonna have one of those uncensored shows
on the front page of timcast.com at
about 10 pm 10 10 pm is when it usually
goes live and uh we'd like to see you
there so become a member support our
work don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show if you really do like it that
one's really important and uh you can
follow the show at Tim cast iron joining
us tonight to talk about this and so
much more is Oren McIntyre hey man
thanks for having me back absolutely who
are you what do you do I'm over at the
blaze got a show there the Oren McIntyre
podcast I've also got a YouTube channel
Twitter all that stuff stuff talking
about political philosophy news of the
day that kind of stuff well right on
thanks for hanging out should be fun
absolutely we got Sheamus my name is
Seamus Coughlin we're on a YouTube
channel called Freedom Tunes we usually
upload Tuesdays and Thursdays but we
decided we're going to upload Friday
this week because we wanted to polish
the video up a little bit more so if you
guys want to go over there and subscribe
we will be releasing that tomorrow we
also have a membership portal at
freedomtunes.com where you can become a
member and get an extra cartoon each
week as well as more behind the scenes
stuff
have fun very fun how you doing I'm Phil
Labonte I am the lead singer of All That
Remains I am an anti-communist and a
counter-revolutionary dude that that
that new song I was blasting it all day
I appreciate that I don't know if I'm
supposed to say anything about the new
All That Remains stuff but no no joke I
was black heard Tim has heard some stuff
and and we are excited to uh present it
it is sufficiently aggressive for the
fall of ideals fans I promise so nice
I've heard some stuff as well it's
pretty good yeah cheers man thank you uh
and I am surge.com I'm ready to get to
it so whenever you are let's jump into
this first story look at this from
newsweek.com CNN cutting Donald Trump
Town Hall short by 20 minutes raises
questions I love this they say uh the
former president 2024 primary Contender
took to the stage blah blah blah in a
statement to Newsweek earlier this week
the network said it was our job despite
his unique circumstances to do what we
do best blah blah we get it Dylan Byers
the senior correspondent at Puck news
two day on Wednesday that the town hall
was scheduled as a 90-minute broadcast
of the network expected the actual event
to go as long as 79 five minutes he went
on to say that it was ended less than 70
minutes in in other words they could
have gone longer if they wanted which is
usually what Executives do with big
ratings draws and it was it pulled in
3.3 million viewers which is massive for
CNN yet for some reason
two interesting things the first
40 minutes in we get this abrupt
commercial and I was like oh they did a
commercial that's weird normally when
they do events like this there's no
commercials and that's it was weird for
us I'm like I guess we're gonna go to
commentary while we wait for the
commercial to pass show comes back for a
few minutes jumps to commercial again
okay that's that's really weird they
come back well that's it for tonight
thanks for hanging out we'll see y'all
later bye off
I wonder what happened what do you got
what do you guys think happened do you
think it was that Trump was just doing
such an amazing job yeah I don't know I
would imagine that's why but it's really
shocking to me that CNN would have the
self-awareness to stop focusing on Trump
when they were getting good ratings from
it because the entire story of 2016 was
them focusing on him Non-Stop and
boosting his public platform all the
while claiming to hate him because they
knew it would pull in more money for
them so it's kind of out of character
for them to try to pull back from Trump
even when the Optics are good for him
you know what I think it is I think CNN
used to be generic corporate press I
used to have CNN on 24 7. I would turn
the TV on put it to CNN and then I would
just start working because when breaking
news would happen they'd be like
breaking news a tornado was touched down
and I'd be like oh wow CNN they get it
quick and then at some point it was just
nothing but Trump and then I was like
okay this is doing nothing for me
there's no news here it was just people
opinion if I turned it off when I turned
it off and a bunch of other moderates
and independents and people like me
turned it off the only people left
standing watching that were anti-trump
Psychopaths which CNN was courting years
later that's the only group of people
who watches the network so when they
said we're gonna do a Donald Trump Town
Hall and Chris lick the CEO is like
we're going to build our our credibility
back up with with America they looked at
what was going on they looked at the
feedback and they were like we are
getting obliterated right now uh cut it
if you were paying attention to Twitter
and stuff the Talk Amongst a lot of the
more vocal leftists was how the audience
response was laughing and and basically
enjoying the Trump show they were you
know laughing and getting along you know
it was great for them and I think that
that was one of the things that really
made a big difference I think that CNN
realized that essentially they were
hurting their Chan their arguments and
allowing Trump to embarrass them and I
think that was one of the big things for
them to to uh take them down I think
that that they the comments on CNN or on
Twitter were making making effect Matt
Gates called it a mercy rule he says
I've never seen a townhouse called like
a mercy rule before that really happened
yes yeah there was a real sense of panic
you could tell that you were not
supposed to allow Trump to kind of have
that magic back again he is in his
element when he's destroying the media
when he's kind of just breaking that
mystery about them you know that that
kind of thin veneer of Civility where
they kind of pretend like they don't
hate America but it's very clear that
they do and he just enrages them the way
that no one else does when he's doing
you know his thing up there and so when
you saw the people laughing when you saw
him joking when you saw him pulling
attention away from the host
embarrassing him when he that moment
when he breaks out his own tweets that
he's printed up I mean you knew it was
done after that yeah they were obviously
losing control yeah absolutely and part
of what's so remarkable about this is
that this was not a trump rally it might
have felt like one but this is a CNN
Town Hall which means the kind of person
going to that is it necessarily who you
would expect to be Trump's demographic
of supporters and he was crushing he was
absolutely killing it there and I think
that made them really Panic too would
you see that clip where they asked the
panel about the town hall and they're
like does it bother you that Trump won't
stop talking about 2020 and the guy goes
you asked him about 2020 and they were
like well well right but you know he
talks about a lot he's like maybe you
could ask him about something else it's
like well yeah yes we could
yeah they screwed this whole thing up I
think Trump did a great job and what CNN
has often done is they've taken clips of
trump out of context to try to make it
as unflattering as possible and I'm not
saying Trump does it or hasn't said
things that are very easy to spin in a
negative way right the guy isn't always
prudent with his choice of words always
hilarious but he's always hilarious and
they just gave that unfiltered
hilariousness directly to Their audience
and they have this woman on stage who's
constantly interrupting constantly
trying to cut him off and constantly
trying to do the finger wagging which
becomes much more obnoxious when you're
there with the person who's entertaining
them right extremely off-putting yes
exactly so if you have footage of trump
killing it at a rally and everyone's
having fun and it's enjoyable and then
you take footage of that and you go this
was bad I'm wagging my finger how
horrible that's kind of annoying right
but if you're at the event actively
trying to stop the fun from happening
those are the worst possible Optics no
one One's On Your Side no one is on your
side why are you trying to throw a wet
blanket on the funny man exactly the
funny man be funny we're having a good
time huh what are you doing we're here
listening to Trump make jokes in exactly
and she became an unwitting performer
right and this is sort of how Michael
malice describes trolling he says
turning someone else into an unwitting
performer which I think can be a solid
definition for what trolling is and
there became something that was kind of
comical about the fact that every time
he was talking no wait no no no no no I
have to I have to I have to correct that
yeah because you're just very nasty it
was the teacher chasing the child as the
child running through the room throwing
stuff and the teachers just running
after the kid trying to get the kid to
sit down and would you put that down and
don't get over here and put that don't
put your don't put your finger in there
that's exactly what she was doing in
Donald Trump
and it's and people are dying and he is
just absolutely making a fool of this
woman well it was wonderful you can
really see that Dynamic when he's like
oh or she kept saying you can't keep
calling it a rigged election you can't
keep saying that it's like I can do it
she has no control over the situation
this is supposed to be an inquisition
they're supposed to bring Trump up there
and hold him accountable and you know
make make the entire audience just see
his evil ways and he's just making them
look hilarious and that's the worst that
can happen when you're trying to be in a
position of authority persecuting
something so so so do you guys think
Trump's back
how is he going to pull with the
American people overall I don't know I
will say this was good for him this was
very good for him best day since I heard
someone's on the on the way in I heard
someone talking about it the best day
since he went to Ohio
what was Ohio when he went to the Ohio
wind at the train derailing oh right
right right right yeah absolutely this
this brought back a lot of that energy
in the beginning it was a little slow it
was a little I was like oh come on man
and then in the end he's standing up and
he's like no no boy you're a nasty woman
was a nasty person something like that
is like you're very nasty he says like
oh boy are you nasty something along
those lines
because what we're getting out of this
town hall is a guy kind of giving us
legitimate answers look I don't do you
want Ukraine to win the war I want
people to stop dying oh oh now now even
Newsweek has it look at this that's a
very good diplomatic answer to that
right because because do you want to go
ahead and be like yeah we have to smash
Russia because you know we're only like
closer to nuclear war than we've been
since the 60s this is what they were
speaking at the Town Hall Trump would
not say whether he wanted Ukraine to win
the war against Russia about it the
Biden admin is supported with Aid and
said the U.S might as well default on
its debt despite warning the potential
or for devastating economic impact if it
did uh I'm all for that like I'm all for
letting the default happen I'm like you
we can't just live this way
I think Trump's strategy on Ukraine I
know what his strategy is it's sit down
with Putin and zielinski and say what
ends this war and then having them both
be like X Y and Z goes done that's it
and that means both parties are going to
be unhappy but the problem is the result
in this country you have to march in
lockstep with the cult and this is why I
say like the the the woke stuff has
nothing to do with leftist ideology in
its root because there's no reason why
Ukraine's war support that the support
for war in Ukraine has nothing to do
with Marxism or communism or any
ideologies or anything like that it's
just you have to be Marching In lockstep
that's what Caitlyn Collins was hoping
to get at Cena was hoping to get do you
want Ukraine to win the war and Trump
says what most Americans probably
accepted and wanted to hear we want
people to stop dying just stop the war
just just make it stop there we go
you can't have that nope gotta shut that
down no as if as if he's supposed to
come out and be some kind of Warhawk of
course that's exactly what they want
like you said they want to go out there
and and basically be as bombastic as he
usually is but with a nuclear-armed
power instead and I'm not saying that
Trump being bombastic has always been a
bad thing with respect to foreign policy
there's a good argument to be made that
his brashness is part of why Putin
didn't invade Ukraine well Trump was in
office and waited until there was a ice
cream loving child sniffing man with
dementia in office to make that move but
she's clearly trying to coax Trump into
saying something that would be bad for a
his Public Image and also the United
States standing on the world stage it's
good that he's handling this as
diplomatically as he is 3.3 million
viewers that's a big deal for CNN you
know they they normally can't muster
that up but uh we got more news
CNN's own employees are disparaging the
Trump town hall employees inside the
company are slamming the network for
giving Trump a platform to spout false
claims on a multitude of issues we have
this uh thread from Brian stelter I love
this one because it shows how out of
touch they are Chris Licht begins CNN's
Dynam editorial call praising Caitlin
Collins for a quote masterful
performance last night he says I
couldn't be more proud of her and the
whole team in New Hampshire then he says
he's aware of the backlash more to come
okay
CNN's doomed if if they thought Caitlin
Collins did a good job that they're just
done it was it was a poor performance by
an individual who should not be in that
position Caitlyn Collins does not have
the Persona the presence the gravitas
the talent capability to stand up
against a Donald Trump figure in this
way she just comes off as whiny the
whole time constantly interrupting him
no fun she was literally the no fun
person but but that's like all the Press
can do at this point right like they all
know that they're not allowed to be
objective anymore they all know that
they're not allowed to let him get up
there and give a fair hearing they all
understand that it's their job to
destroy this person publicly and if they
don't do that they're going to get
criticized for being too light on Trump
for facilitating him for you know and
putting him up there and so they
understand that they have to just Badger
him like this and it doesn't matter how
ridiculous they look because they don't
care about the audience and they don't
care about the ratings they care about
the approval of their friends they care
about the approval of the crowd they
care about their standing in the
Progressive Movement that's all that
matters they're not Journal homeless in
any kind of significant way that you
think about they are very clearly
Democratic apparatchics and that's the
only measure of success they have this
is this is really good news really
really good news they are eating
themselves from the inside they can't
this was 3.3 million viewers CNN needs
this kind of traffic they need to go on
TV and have a real conversation about
what Americans actually want they can't
because the cult is holding them down by
their ankles this just means seeing and
I hope you're listening CNN or if you
work there your company is crumbling
because you are a zombie cult and I
don't care in fact I'm ready to crack
open that Louis XII and share a little
bottle of fine cognac to celebrate the
demise of CNN I can't wait for it
we'll mix it with Diet Coke yeah maybe
MTV News just died BuzzFeed news is over
vices nearing bankruptcy it's amazing
well Soros I guess is bailing out Vice
and now CNN can't even do any it's like
I just want to say how funny it is that
CNN is desperate saying please help us
watch our Channel and they finally got
something Trump and they're like this
might save us and the left comes with
pitchforks crowbars and baseball
struggle sessions
and it's like Oren said every single
move that they make is calculated to
boost their own personal social credit
score every single one of these people
all that matters is that those around
them say you were a good Progressive you
behaved well you did what you were
supposed to do you pushed back properly
none of it's about trying to find Common
Ground none of it's about trying to get
more information for Their audience
about the 2020 election about the Russia
Ukraine conflict about any other
relevant issue it's about showing them
that I'm good because I don't like Trump
we are we are closer to nuclear war than
we have been since the 60s it is an
actual possibility that I mean no one
would be completely and utterly shocked
if Putin launched a couple nuclear uh
artillery strikes well in Ukraine would
become it wouldn't be like oh my God
that came out of nowhere no they're at
War and they've got there's a lot of
people dying and that is something that
could actually happen I want to tell you
what I see when I watch a CNN thing it
feels like I went to a skate park and
they didn't say anything about that it
feels like I'm at a skate park and
there's a bunch of little kids on
scooters riding around and you're like
these kids don't know etiquette they're
going the wrong way and it's very
dangerous because if you're if you're
going fast you're gonna do a big old
kickflip you crash into one of these
kids you get hurt the kid gets hurts
like oh that's what I see when I watch
CNN Caitlin Collins is a really really
good example of this it's obvious she
has no idea what she's talking about
she has no views of her own to actually
insert to to debate Trump with so
instead she's just debating him in a
generic
and my favorite example is when Trump
said that he offered the National Guard
to DC but it was rejected she goes
that's not true your own Chris Chris
Miller that didn't happen
it is literally true she was
interrupting Trump and she was wrong
factually wrong that's the worst thing
so you you have someone if Caitlyn comes
as a pundit of someone who who opines on
issues and no and has an in-depth view
on these things and wanted to push back
on Trump I'd be like that's interesting
it's a debate but she's supposed to be a
moderator and what a moderator does says
Trump here's a question what do you
think interesting how do you respond to
this question if if Trump said look you
know I was I was offering up National
Guard and they didn't want it they said
no then said well Chris Miller wrote in
his book that you did not authorize the
deployment then you'd say I did offer it
to DC and they said no so there is a
difference in the moderation moderate
moderator should then say
it's all about boosting that social
credit score you made a very good point
about the fact that there is a very high
risk of nuclear war any risk is too much
risk in some sense but instead of
focusing on that and and changing the
conversation any questions about it but
instead of engaging that question with
any level of social responsibility she
wanted Trump to be as inflammatory and
bombastic as possible and instead of
focusing on the possibility of nuclear
war
the left instead wants to prioritize the
fact that you drove your car too many
miles last week and that's making the
weather angry right like their
apocalyptic fears are of things that
everyday Americans do in order to live
their lives and they involve basically
no focus on powerful people who are
profiting millions even billions of
dollars off of these conflicts overseas
that we don't need to be involved with
which could legitimately result in
millions and millions and millions of
deaths I I I do want to give a shout out
to our friend Sunny Hosten over at the
view for trashing Caitlyn Collins over
the Trump Town Hall Fiasco masterful job
wow I agree with her wow she was
surprised Kalyn Collins exemplified what
it means to be a world-class journalist
she asked tough fair questions CNN send
a statement at the Town Hall and she
followed up with the fact followed up in
fact checked Trump in real time to arm
voters with crucial information that's
what CNN is is betting on activism
to be honest I didn't like the platform
but I also want to say this because I
know she's getting Flack from from some
folks killing counts did a masterful job
Griffin noted masterful job wow as a
young woman seeing a 30 year old
journalist take it to one of the most
powerful men in the world Griffin
continued as Hospital snide asides she
got in there it's really easy Austin
then proceeded to uh to Monday Morning
Quarterback it well we get it I think I
think she did a terrible job and if CNN
is betting on that I'm just really
excited that's like at least Don Lemon
had
some fire in him you know what I mean
like Don Lemon was a crazy man but he
would argue with Vivek and you'd be like
I can't believe he's actually like but
you knew it was coming you knew he was
Kalyn Collins it's like putting a a
mannequin on stage and then like pulling
the rip cord and she's like no Trump you
are wrong well the one difference is she
never asked him whatever your ethnicity
is well she was scolding him yeah that
would have been I mean yeah at this
point they just don't understand how to
handle him he doesn't care he doesn't
give them the respect they believe they
deserve they're so inept they've never
run into anyone who doesn't just
automatically genuflect in front of them
because they're the media and they're
the king makers and you're they're the
ones that have to be served at any
moment because they control your image
and that's what Trump does so well he
has the image maybe it's not always a
great one sometimes he goes you know
wild but he's the one in control he's
the one in the driver's seat and it
drives them nuts I mean what are they
gonna do they've called this guy Hitler
they've called this guy Satan are they
going to pretend like he had a good
performance so they could pretend like
their person did a bad job they've got
to lie about it it's the only thing
they've got left and that's why they
keep looking more and more ridiculous
yeah no I wonder how much they pay her
Caitlyn Collins we talked about it last
night 77 cents on the dollar for the men
they have working there Tim and it's a
problem and it's a problem well actually
let me let me let me let me do something
you know she made significantly less
money than the man she was on stage with
last night significantly lower net worth
overall
let's do it explain that to me Don
lemon's salary because I don't
understand why the world check it out
the New York Times in April said Don
lemon's salary was seven million all
right let's do uh Caitlyn Collins salary
here and uh Google says one to three
million
so it's it's worse that 77 cents on the
dollar Sheamus I think that Don Lemon
like 40 cents on the dollar and I'm sure
they pull in the exact same numbers for
the network I'd be curious to see how
much viewership Don Lemon pulls in as
opposer because this could be a classic
example of workplace sexism and I think
Don needs to acknowledge his unearned
privilege well apparently now they're
going to give her Cuomo's time slot her
it's really sad she's getting a that's
the that's I think that's confirmed
actually oh my that she's getting the 9
pm CNN time slot and uh it's just not no
like Aaron Burnett I get like and
Anderson Cooper I get Caitlyn Collins
it's like a mannequin on TV it's just
like looking at a chunk of plastic with
a with a mouth just goes wrong there's
nothing there that's how you view women
it's him no just Caitlin sounds like
Aaron Burnett actually as like sexist
animal but it's not sexist if I
compliment another woman
no well no any anytime you say it no no
Tim I don't think you understand it's
like I had my fingers crossed time you
criticize any person from any group that
means you hate the entire group do you
understand oh yeah sorry buddy you're
going to sex this jail
now I think um I was like I talked about
this earlier like Dana Bash like CNN has
female personalities and male personnels
and you get it
Caitlyn Collins I don't understand
they're just like help we need young
people what do we do like this is the
best we could do I don't know throw
spaghetti at the wall and see what
sticks
I want to figure out her ratings as
opposed to Don lemon's ratings to see if
she's getting ripped off I don't I don't
I'll I will negotiate for it I will go
to that Network and let them know that
she's worth more now Don lemon's not
there anymore maybe they couldn't afford
him giving his ratings I don't know but
I think it's telling that he makes so
much more than her and he's a man I we
made but I actually fair point I think
we do need to uh every every one of us
tweeted CNN and demand they pay Caitlin
Collins exactly what they pay Anderson
Cooper it is not fair it's not fair and
and when she takes if she takes up the 9
pm slot she should get 100 the same
amount that Cuomo got that's how it
works and what was Cuomo's salary do we
know what Cuomo salary was Sheamus I
like your turn is the new glorious
Steinem thank you well look I I someone
has to continue the Legacy it's very
important and what I will say is that
according to two different sources
Anderson Cooper salary is 12 million
dollars
12 men I don't want to live in a country
where everyone isn't making 12 million
dollars a year right like remember when
uh Bloomberg spent 500 million dollars
on the election to get heckled that was
great to get bullied that means there's
300 million people in the United States
he could have given every American 1
million dollars remember that lady said
that
yes it's actually a dollar Thirty not a
million dollars I think everyone gets a
dollar oh my God yeah oh no no I think
if CNN doesn't pay Caitlin Collins 12
million dollars it proves they're sexist
that's exactly right then by the way
what is the money somewhere I think the
average share in the national debt per
person is about two hundred thousand
dollars so just to be clear just to be
clear with the sum of money that Tim
just laid out that would give every
person one dollar and thirty cents right
you want to do the math on confiscating
all the wealth from all the billionaires
the way they talk about to fund all
their social programs like we literally
wouldn't even make a dent in the money
that we owe how about we do this if you
want to vote you have to pay more in
taxes than the national debt per person
oh my gosh you have to pay off your
share of the national debt so if it's
200 000 per person and rising and it's
out of your control you would need to
make what is that so uh that so you'd
have to make like 500 000 a year well no
no you just pay off your share of the
debt once
oh yeah good point yeah yeah you just
you pay off your share of the debt once
and now now you get to vote I think I
think that's the only like 10 people
voting all right ladies and Gentlemen
let's let's see let's get serious we
have this story for the New York posters
big news Daniel Penny to surrender and
face second degree manslaughter charge
in Jordan Neely chokehold that's right
despite the fact that we have video
showing he tried to save the life of
this man despite the fact we know this
man had been arrested dozens of times
kidnapped a child punched an old man in
the face punched a woman in the face we
know that he was threatening people on
the train and said he didn't care if he
got hurt or went to jail three men took
it upon themselves to subdue him this
guy is going up to surrender for
manslaughter charges
up to 15 years in prison I would not be
surprised if he is convicted and
sentenced to the maximum that's it
I wouldn't be surprised if he was
convicted uh I would I would hope that
the judge wouldn't send some sentence
him to the maximum but uh I don't I have
no faith in in New York's justice system
to not considering the pressures that
would come from the activists and the
the uh the left it more broadly he's got
almost no chance he shouldn't he wasn't
initially even charged like they had to
go to a grand jury it's not like it was
they did not go to a grand jury oh they
didn't they did not go to a grand jury
nope they just decided you know I want
to charge them no that's yeah that that
only makes the uh
my opinion of the whole thing worse and
it makes my opinion of the outcome
more dire I suppose I don't I don't see
this guy getting out of it in in one
piece
pessimistic no I mean I think the only
things that are illegal in New York at
this point are political opposition
self-defense and desecrating the pride
flag right like that's the only thing
that'll actually hold you accountable
for you can't be surprised it's it's an
arco-tierney at this point the the whole
reason you're out there is you let these
people lose you let them terrorize the
average person terrorize the population
and then as soon as anyone stands up for
themselves then you go ahead and strike
them down you know for daring to you
know uh take care of themselves and not
rely entirely on the state it's very
clear the state's not going to do its
job it's not going to protect these
people it's only going to persecute
people who it they disagree with and
then as soon as you step up and you try
to take care of yourself you're out of
there and I I don't understand how
anyone's still living in these places at
this point it's horrific
so uh here's a quote it's it is stunning
that they would make an arrest before
presenting this to a grand jury defense
attorney and former Manhattan prosecutor
Mark betterow said Thursday following
news of the charges Bragg made a
political call he now owns this
absolutely it's political we all saw
this coming we knew it was going Kim
Potter she's the cop who the guy dives
into his car and she reaches for her gun
she thought she was tasing him she yells
taser but then shoots him and kills him
and when that happened we were like oh
she's going to prison and she did she
recently got out we do have a give send
go for Daniel Penny's legal defense fund
which is currently at 71 332 but if I
refresh it it'll go up refresh now
ninety thousand dollars see this defense
fund was launched before the charges
were announced now that they've been
announced it seems that people are
flocking to it and giving this man money
and I won't
we were talking about this earlier and
I've been talking about this quite a bit
and I talked about this with Kim Potter
years ago
look I hope this guy gets acquitted I
think it's terrible what they're doing
to him but at a certain point I'm just
wondering why it is that people keep
sending their money into burning
buildings that where the fires aren't
being put out like we're talking about
the city of New York engulfed in
figurative flames and people being like
I'm gonna go walk in there and you're
like nah dude like come on seriously man
don't go in they're like no I'm gonna go
in there like if you go in there you're
gonna get burned I'm gonna go in there
then they walk in start screaming help
help them on fire like I'm not gonna go
in that building I just think I think
it's it's ridiculous at this point so
here's what ends up happening
people on the right Libertarians post
liberals disaffected liberals
send money to the defense of people who
are choosing to live in places where we
know they will destroy you unjustly and
it drains resources from us it takes
money from you and that's probably on
purpose it's like the villain when the
superhero is like I'm Superman and you
can't stop me and then the Joker's like
oh yeah and then points the weapon at
the kid and then Superman's like oh no
now you've got me because I care about
other people this is what they're doing
they're holding us hostage keeping us
off base by targeting innocent people
and threatening them with 15 years in
prison but look it's tough I don't want
this guy going to jail I think he was
doing the right thing protecting other
people and clearly these two other guys
agreed with them and helped him subdue
this guy but at what point in the
passengers thanked him right and then he
tried to save the guy's life but at what
point are we going to be like we can't
keep throwing money at people who choose
to live in communist jurisdictions I
mean you see this all the time you see
these videos and people all say why
isn't anyone stepping up you watch
someone harassing a homeless person or
some crazy person attacking people
getting by island with people and
they're like why aren't the men stepping
in why aren't they taking action and
this is the answer everyone understood
what was going to happen here especially
again due to the racial Dynamic let's be
really honest this guy's white the guy
who died is black and that's all that
mattered before anything else that's all
that matter that's what everyone saw
it's what all the Liberals were acting
on and this guy had to be held
accountable because they're gonna hold
this guy up as being murdered they're
already talking about oh he's a really
kind guy he's having a lot of mental
health troubles as a you know very sweet
person who's you know performing on the
subway with Michael Jackson impersonator
no he's a violent criminal he had felony
charges out against him as very clearly
he's a threat to everyone around him the
city made sure that he was still in
public and as soon as anyone stood up to
him they're in terrible trouble I know
that people want to stay in these areas
I understand I have a lot of friends who
say we have to stay in these areas
because this is where culture happens
this is where decisions happens but at
this point I don't know how you say yeah
you have you're gonna have a family here
where you know that they're encouraging
violence and you know that it's illegal
for you to defend yourself I mean how
can you you just can't exist in this
place and culture is dying Disney is
losing scribers by the millions and your
vote doesn't matter in places like New
York City but if you move to a suburb of
New York or even you know a swing state
move to Ohio move to Georgia and go to a
suburban area that desperately needs
your vote and that's the front line of
what's going on what's Happening Now is
people are like I'm gonna choose to stay
Behind Enemy Lines and then ask you for
resources and it's just like dude
you know you know what I want to donate
to I want to donate to a small business
in Georgia right now I want to donate to
Scott Pressler I don't want this guy
going to prison but it's like how do we
have to allocate funds to a guy who's
like captured effectively but chose to
go there and is not doing anything in
terms of winning a culture War y'all who
are in these cities I know it's hard but
if you move to Ohio and move to a
suburban area that was purple and
shifted everything red we would be
winning instead there are people who are
choosing to live in places like New York
and then being surprised is happening if
you live in New York City I mean I'm not
sure exactly how far away the corner of
Pennsylvania is but I know it's a you
know like an hour and a half or
something like that it's possible you
could move to Pennsylvania and still
work in New York if you got to stay
there but get out of the Cities I mean I
moved to New Hampshire a decade and
change ago
um because I wanted to get out of
Western Massachusetts because I didn't
want you know the laws that
Massachusetts had in Massachusetts at
the time was not nearly the place that
it is now so I mean you're in control of
your own life you can't control what
your neighbors are voting for you can't
control what the people down the street
are voting for you can control where you
live get out of City cities and make
sure that you are taking care of you and
your family yeah if you think you're
going to be the person who saves
Illinois or New York or California just
know that you're liable to have this
happen to you or one of your children or
to have your children be put on puberty
blockers and taken from being mutilated
in New York City there are violent
protests against this man against him
people are not protesting for him they
are Marching violently and attacking
cops because they hate him I do not see
that as a salvageable place no one in
New York likes what he did the people of
New York like this you see the video of
the woman getting punched in the face
she tells like I take a chill pill and
he clocks her cleaning the face that was
two years ago 2022 comes around they
vote for it again
what are we supposed to do
just tell them like okay keep doing it
nah look
obviously the woman got punched in the
face did not want to get punched in the
face but she'll still vote for the same
policies obviously the woman in San
Francisco who was dragged to death did
not want that to happen to her she was
robbed She chased after the people who
robbed her they murdered her her friend
was on her way to her vigil she got
mercilessly beaten and curb stomped
literally they stomped on her head on a
curb
but these people despite these things
will come out and be like I feel bad for
the perpetrator how many times have we
heard these life has come out and and
apologize for the person who victimized
them
like at a certain point these cities are
just not salvageable like and it's been
years of this so we need we need to be
on the front line winning a culture war
and that means getting your family
somewhere where your vote matters
substantially more and doesn't matter in
New York or San Francisco
are you gonna donate James
I don't well thanks for putting me on
the spot uh I don't know yeah looking at
his legal fund I I certainly I'd have to
look into it but I think it's I think
it's a worthy cause I hear what you're
saying these places are incredibly
dangerous uh if I had a family I
absolutely would not stay in New York
now I understand this is easy for me to
say because I'm not tied to a career in
a particular area but I also know people
who have moved out of cities in order to
protect their family and that's supposed
to be your number one priority the
reason in truth right if if you're a
married person well what's the point of
your career if not to support your kids
and if you have to stay in an area where
your kids are going to be harmed in
order to have your career I think it's
obvious that it's not worth it I have a
friend that I was just talking to today
that lives in in the city and he's going
to get uh trying to get a permit to
carry I'm he knows that he's probably
not going to get it in the city but he's
trying to get it for Nassau County but
anyways he uh he went and had the class
today and he was talking to the
instructor and they were going down the
uh the list of the laws and what is and
is not acceptable or legal in in New
Orkin he was totally unaware that
essentially he couldn't defend his own
life in New York He was unaware that if
he shot someone that was in his home in
his home armed if he shot them and he
didn't kill them that they would sue him
and they would probably win and that the
family even if he did kill him the
family was going to assume has no idea
your average voter is unaware of the
circumstances that they live in so again
it's one thing to be like oh I want to
be in the city Etc you should probably
check out the laws in your area you
should be aware of the voting record of
your the prosecution record of your D.A
before you vote for the D.A you should
probably be aware of who your D.A is
before you vote for them
um and if you're in a city it's probably
too late but when you when you actually
decide to get out and go to another
place be aware of the people that are
running so the new place that you go to
doesn't turn into the garbage place that
you left let me let me jump to this
story here about another crime that took
place in New York City homeless man
charged with hate crimes for defecating
on Pride flags at Manhattan Eatery
they're trying to give him the maximum
sentence blasphemy laws yep they said
that uh him taking a dump on a pride
flag and wiping his butt with it was a
hate crime and intolerance you know I
think I think he's just some homeless
guy who's looking for a place to take a
dump that's it and they're like why
didn't use napkins and I'm like I don't
know that he was thinking at all why did
the guy in the subway platform push the
woman onto the into the front of the
train why did he murder her I mean these
people aren't well when it comes to the
guy in the train who is desperate and
hungry what did AOC say it should not be
a death sentence for this man who is
just hungry and unwell into the city's
fault
is this man not hungry and unwell when
he pooped in a pride flag exactly so so
I mentioned this the other day whenever
it comes to an act of Senseless violence
a million and one different excuses are
made and we have to go into a deep
socioeconomic analysis of what could
have led that person who we think is a
criminal but is truly a victim to feel
that they needed to commit that
disordered act and then of course when
you speak out against the party you're
not afforded that same luxury they don't
make a million and one excuses they
don't play mental gymnastics to make
what you did seem okay within their
framework because we just never funded
that inner city library that would have
educated you and made you a more
enlightened functioning member of
society and in part it's because
when you go out against the narrative
because they're single-minded that means
you are responsible for all of the
world's ills the reason violent crime
happens is because we're not allocating
our resources properly and under the
religion of Marxism simply moving
material things around in the material
world solves all of the problems let's
put the wealth here instead of there and
then there won't be any more crime we'll
stop it all from happening and because
you're not on board with that you're
responsible for every violent act so by
simply criticizing the Party by doing
what he did in disgracing or desecrating
an lgbtq flag
he is contributing to Serious violence
this is actually how their minds work
because he's taking away from The
credibility of their philosophy which
will fix everything if we just let it
take a look at this story from Daily
Mail
Cleaver wielding convict terrorizes Bart
trained passengers trapped in underwater
tunnel by pacing up and down train
threatening them then slashing man in
the back if only we built that inner
city library if you try in any way to
stop this man you will go to prison
you must allow him to chop you into
pieces before you try to defend yourself
well we saw this
archipelago every society every society
has something they hold sacred there
there's no escaping this we all do it
every society does this and we pretend
like we're Beyond it we're pretend like
we'd be Advanced behind this Behavior no
you haven't you will have something
sacred and for us it is this diversity
equity and inclusion it is the pride
flag it is the racial hierarchy for us
these are the things but but
increasingly it is at the cult I think
it is becoming the values of the nation
I think it is becoming the values of
almost every institution from the
military to the media and look obviously
I'm against this stuff but I think it's
hard to pretend like this isn't not now
come to dominate the vast majority I
know I I think I think you're wrong I
think Budweiser proves the people of
this country do not hold these things
sacred that's that's the difference
though you're you're you're correct that
it's not it's not a Grassroots popular
thing it's totally AstroTurf and you're
right it's coming from the institutions
because the people that are going to
school and graduating as the C
graduating and going on to be CEOs and
stuff they're bringing this into the
into the boardroom with them there was a
long time where people thought kids were
going to go to school they were going to
do this stuff in sociology and in the
humanities and then they would get out
into the real world and the real world
would fix them well guess what they're
bringing it into the boardroom and
making it they're putting it into the HR
departments and making it the standard
culture in broader society and culture
is Downstream from power it does not
matter what the average person thinks it
doesn't matter what the masses think it
matters who the influential people The
Taste makers the institutions the power
Brokers it matters what they think
because they then inform what people
think how popular was trans and kids
five years ago oh not at all yeah just
five years ago it didn't exist right and
now it's everywhere it's the dominant
dominant thing it's the center of the
cultural battle why is that because 70
of America suddenly decided they really
cared about mutilating children no it's
because they were told what to care
about and so but I think it was actually
because people on the Right started
pushing back against it and then the
left started widely promoting it
in in popular media well
it's complicated right because this is
what the left one of the stuff Force
something onto the general culture just
as you've mentioned very powerful people
will start pushing this stuff they'll
put it on television they'll promote it
on social media they'll have the
algorithm Orient people towards this
kind of content that normalizes this
truly abhorrent disgusting perverted
behavior in the abuse of children and
then when normal healthy people who
aren't just gonna go along with what the
culture tells them they should believe
say that's sick because that is the
mutilation of children their response is
why do you care so much why do you care
so much people are always going to be
trans people have been trans you know
etc etc but your average answer
what when someone says why you care so I
do have an answer I do have an answer to
that question I'm saying for the average
person oh yeah yeah know your answer
absolutely absolutely and you should be
able to have an answer to that question
but my point is that they play this game
where they make something an issue and
then they ask why you're paying
attention to it
will they create the problem because
they believe they have the solution and
because the dialectic gets Advanced that
way right because now you need to
moderate it okay you didn't even have a
position on this before but now you need
a more moderate position so you can find
some kind of consensus inside a
dialectic that was created for you
artificially yeah so this wasn't even
you didn't need to have this debate and
now it's essentially you for not only to
have this debate but to move your
position in that debate closer to
whatever the progressive position is and
that is a key thing that people have to
understand exactly and that's why
conservatives end up letting go of
cultural ground because what happens is
first people understand that like
marriage between a man and woman for the
purposes of procreation well now
contraceptive starts to become
normalized and conservatives start to
fight that and then people start talking
about gay marriage and okay now fighting
contraceptive seems outdated we're going
to try to fight gay marriage now people
have decided that two men can be married
even though that's literally impossible
given the definition of the term but now
they're saying that we can trans
children a man can become a woman you go
over there and you try to fight that now
again they're pushing it onto kids so
conservatives jump from fight to fight
to fight to fight because the left keeps
setting
I got a question for you guys if uh uh
if an antifa guy was on a subway and it
happened to him that some guy like
started beating the crap out of him and
then he got into a fight and I was
getting arrested how would you feel wait
can you repeat that like the antifa guy
wearing an answer Defender herself is on
a train
and some guys threatening people and the
guy in the antifa shirt grabs a guy and
subdues him and gets arrested for it how
do you feel
I feel about the same way
so you would donate to the antifa guy's
defense I'm not donating to his
son no no I wouldn't but people
listening I'd love to hear your thoughts
would you if there was a guy wearing a
Bernie Sanders 2024 or Joe Biden Biden
Harris 2024 shirt and
and he grabbed this guy and and you know
because the guy was on the train
threatening people would you would you
donate to them
that's a good question I mean if he was
an antifa I wouldn't need to donate to
him because no one would try to press
charges I'm saying if they did my point
is you get these people who live in
these cities and there's an 85 chance
this guy is a Democrat voter and
everyone's like quick quick give him
give him money and I'm like I mean maybe
is he a guy who actually believes in
American values who is fighting for
those values or is it the overwhelming
likelihood 85 that somebody who lives in
these cities especially after we've seen
the mass Exodus from moderates and
conservatives the likelihood is even
greater this is some Biden voter who is
getting what he voted for no I mean I
hear you I'm 100 behind the right having
legal defense funds and standing up for
people I think that's a level of
infrastructure that absolutely has to
happen but you have to use that wisely
you can't just throw it for people who
are in you know like said putting
yourself in that situation likely
political enemies you should be putting
it towards people who you know are going
to be using it properly so I'm generally
in favor of these organizations existing
people making these kind of donations
but you do have to be thinking about
what you're actually applying that to
people can give whatever they want I'm I
I hope this guy does not go to prison I
hope he wins I'm glad people are
supporting him I'm just saying at what
point are we going to be like look I'll
put it this way I left New York a long
time ago because a black supremacist
murdered some cops and I said I am not
going to live in a place that is like
this I am not going to have my tax
dollars go to a city one of the it's the
one of the only stages of income tax and
one of the highest income taxes for a
resident in the in the country in the
world and then I'm in the Jersey side
someone plants bombs and I'm like okay
better not be in this place but we end
up in a place where where we're at in
the tri-state the the tri-state area and
the Eastern panhandle of West Virginia
is moderately purple for for the area
you've got Maryland which of course is a
is a major Battleground and and very
left very Democrat and then the Eastern
panhandles is maybe surprising people of
West Virginia the schools are very very
welcome they're trying to indoctrinate
kids so now I feel pretty good about
where I'm at I feel safe I have
constitutional carry but we're in a
local jurisdiction where there's a
actually some serious concerns with the
school board and recently the GOP was
talking about despite the fact that
they've won the school board they still
have this woke stuff that they're trying
to push out because this is a key
Battleground now my concern is are we
giving money to Democrats who voted for
this because we're not paying attention
and we assume because this guy did a
good thing that he is a good guy I mean
if this if it turns out this guy doesn't
really live there I just moved there and
he's a big Trump supporter and he's been
fighting against this stuff and he's
been posting about it I'll be like okay
this is a guy needs our help Kyle
Rittenhouse is in a suburban area he was
in he was in a split area uh politically
and he was there as an innocent kid
trying to help clean up his neighborhood
actively fighting for his neighborhood
and trying to help even the protesters
and that was years ago and we're like
okay now it's several years on and we're
immediately knee-jerk jumping to the
defense of a guy we don't know
who could turn out to be the biggest Joe
Biden supporter who voted for all of
this and that's my concern giving money
to the people who are making the problem
happen if you live in New York
especially after the Summer of Love
riots especially after Chauvin Ahmed
Arbury Kim Potter Etc
especially after even the the 25 people
being shoved in front of trains the
likelihood is not that this person is
someone who believes in our values and
is going to be fighting for them the
likelihood is it's just some default
liberal guy who's supporting Joe Biden
so I'll I'll wait and I'll see you know
we'll see how this plays out but that's
my biggest concern are we as people who
want to push back who are buying
Jeremy's chocolate who are who are
buying Jeremy's razors then going to
donate to Democrats when they get
themselves in trouble are we going to be
the people who are contributing to the
bail funds of of antifolic extremists
when Kamala Harris and Joe Biden's staff
raised money for the far left Riders we
were like this is abhorrent how this is
ridiculous how dare you do this so my
question now is when you get people who
live in these cities
the overwhelming likelihood that they
support these things so so what is what
is that issue right now is it that we
assume he must not support these things
because he tried to subdue a crazy
person
no I don't necessarily believe that the
woman who got punched in the face
clearly didn't want to get punched in
the face but you know she votes Democrat
this this pink-haired hippie lady who
lives in New York City it's a 90 chance
she did and you go and talk to these
people and you ask them like are you
gonna vote Democrat they'll say yes in
fact what about the rise and crime will
say I don't care or that woman in San
Francisco said I will never call the
police and then she gets murdered are we
gonna donate to people like that I don't
know man that's tough there's I don't
find any significant flaw with what
you're saying like I personally I don't
see a whole lot of reason to donate to
people that to that live in cities like
you say it's like they're there they
stay there that's what they're asking
for that's what they want most people
again aren't aware of the aren't even
aware of their situation so I I don't
see a big reason to to argue with you
about it I mean look we'll see people
are saying that he's from Long Island
he's a Marine he's probably not a
Democrat and it's like okay you know
like let's let's see what he has to say
when he put a statement he his lawyer
could have put out a statement that said
something like New York has seen violent
crime escalating rapidly for several
years and the people of the city are
tired of it when this man violently
threatened the passengers of this train
Daniel um our client Daniel Penny along
with two others found it reasonable to
try and subdue him to protect the lives
of others did they do that no they said
it's so sad and unfortunate that people
are suffering in this city
they they gave a woke they were awoke
statement that many conservatives
started complaining about on Twitter but
now they're willing to throw money at
these people who are just giving this
like default tepid response
I just think I don't know man
don't don't look at me I don't have all
the answers y'all can do what you want
you know yeah I'm surprised he hasn't
come out and said anything at all if we
were to come out and he did well did he
justify his position no yeah they they
they the statement they issued on his
behalf was just lamenting the poor
homeless of New York City I will say the
point of that statement though is to try
to Defuse The the protest you're
supposed to as opposed to so I mean you
may it may not be well that's what he's
trying to do and to be honest with you
if you're in that situation I get a dude
who's not really like engulfed in the
culture War I can get why he'd be like
yo what do I what am I supposed to do to
calm people down and get myself out of
that there there is the again people
don't know what they you know people
don't know the laws that they live under
most of the time they don't realize what
laws get passed uh and they don't pay a
whole lot of attention to politics they
should absolutely I'm not saying that
you know their ignorance is is uh is
fine or whatever but at the same time
it's like he's probably got no idea what
he's gotten himself into and he's like
like what do I do to make this go away
and so so often there's just no
connection with these people I live down
in Florida and we get all these people
down from New York come down they move
they can't believe what's happened in
New York they don't want to live there
anymore they're finally out of there but
what's the first thing they do when they
come down to Florida oh I can't believe
what DeSantis is doing I can't believe
all these things that you're living here
I can't believe your politics are like
this it's like there's no connection
they don't they they genuinely do not
understand how one thing leads to the
next they just come down and think oh
well there's some kind of magical reason
that this place is safer there was that
Viral thread where a guy from San
Francisco was like we moved to Florida
because the crime was getting too bad
and then someone said just you know
don't don't vote Democrat and then
someone leftist was like you're going to
support DeSantis and his response was
immediately to be like no no I'm left
wing and I'm going to vote Democrat oh
my gosh well this is part of the
complexity here right so you were
mentioning earlier that we want people
to leave these cities if they're you
know and at all decent person but then
when people leave and they end up voting
for the same policies it makes
everything worse in the states they go
to and I know ideal you would have
conservatives leaving New York and go
into a place like Florida but I'm sorry
a New York conservative is not the same
as a Florida I do think that the the
viewership of of timcast is probably the
kind of people that we're talking to it
matters I I don't expect that people
that would be you know tuning in to
timcast and say you know what Tim's
right I'm going to move would be the
kind of people that would be like oh now
I'm completely gonna vote I was in I was
in Chicago I had a couple hundred bucks
and I just left now and I went to I went
to California and I was just like I'm
I'm leaving this place crime corruption
police were were uh like all the stories
a cop choke slams a woman because a
meter maid the the police are operating
black sites and I'm like I definitely
don't want to be here and so I'm gonna
get out and granted house 23 is easy for
a 23 year old but there was a lot of
risk I was planning on being homeless
and I got I got lucky in finding a place
and meeting some people I got to sleep
on a couch periodically and sleep on the
floor
I'm just saying like at this point we've
already seen most people flee to Florida
and now Rhonda Santos is winning by a
million votes people fled to Texas
that's where the biggest uh uh influx of
new American of of migrants was American
internal where they call it net
migration people fled California they
fled New York
I don't know why we care so much about
these places New York and California you
know what I mean
like the the corruption is off the
charts like that you've got in San
Francisco Cleaver wielding convict
terrorizing the train aoc's not saying
anything about this did she come out and
say like we really got to stop these
people terrorizing said is it like no I
don't know at a certain point I'm like
bro you reap what you sow you live there
you live there
well what AOC has said is we need a
National Railway system and I can't wait
to see how safe and wonderful that is
it'll be really good news when all those
people from New York can get right to
Florida in just a moment I still really
appreciate that that'll be awesome so I
get one of the one of the nice things
about the United States one of the
things that makes it work is that we can
be far away from you guys they keep
saying it's kind of nice they keep
saying we need a nationwide rail service
and I keep saying why because they want
to go out of planes exactly well they
want to get rid of planes they want to
get rid of automobiles they want you to
have zero privacy or autonomy you gotta
be on the mass transit so you have to be
on the the large uh Mass the high-speed
Railway system with the rambling
homeless person who's swinging a machete
at people
maybe that's it for real though no it is
a lot of a lot of Subway crime has been
popping up in all of these cities and
they want to take away your ability to
have a car they want to put you in this
yeah I want to take away your ability to
defend yourself yeah the whole point of
Prosecuting you I think they might just
want you to die you know what I mean I
mean you are the carbon that they want
to eliminate I mean if you're going to
have a total state if you're gonna have
a totalitarian state you got to get rid
of individuality and communities you got
to get rid of the autonomy that little
Regional communities provide the ability
people to get away you have to make
everybody dependent on the system so
yeah I think that's absolutely you have
to convince people that the Senate is is
uh undemocratic and good I'm glad more
on democracy please
you know exactly why they want to get
rid of oh I know the Senate it's not
like it's going to be some kind of
positive thing if they were to get rid
of the Senate
um but you know that the point of
getting rid of the Senate is because
they want to you know they don't want to
have states that are individuated and
have have autonomy and stuff that to the
progressives is bad so yeah I wonder if
if a lot you know these people are
malthusian they think there's too many
people and they want to get rid of them
I wonder if a lot of these policies
aren't necessarily about individually
killing any person it's about creating a
net pressure which results in the long
term with a declining population
I mean they don't have to do that that's
already happening the social
engineering's already getting them there
if they did it right then that's the
point that's what I'm saying like are
these policies put in place for the
reason of creating a pressure which
results in a lower population the thing
is I don't even know I don't think it's
that well thought out I just think that
Society is a thing that people have to
constantly work to upkeep and progress
so it's not something that someone just
built for us and then left here and we
can allow to sit it has to constantly be
up cupped by people living virtuous
lives and when you don't want to live a
virtuous life you just rationalize that
and when you try to rationalize that in
a wide scale political sense you just
call it leftism so all these policies
are are people attempting to rationalize
the abdication of their responsibility
to uphold our society and culture well I
can I can put another way for you
Sheamus there was this uh TV show
where they were tracking fat women and
it was like why why are they fat or
whatever and This Woman's like I have a
glandular problem and then what they did
was they filmed her throughout the day
and they were like at the end they said
how much how many calories do you think
you ate and she was like probably 1200
for I had a light breakfast with just
some eggs for lunch I had a salad and
for dinner I had you know small steak
and they were like you had
4763 calories like what and then they
showed the video of her grabbing cookies
and candies and snack cakes and stuff
like that all throughout the day and
that that to me is it the
rationalization of it's just one cupcake
yes it's only to 150 calories to have a
one cup it doesn't matter and then you
do it a hundred times well yeah exactly
and that and that's how Vice works right
when a person builds virtually they're
not going I only won you don't have to
rationalize it in that way
so what ends up happening is there are
people who are doing things anything
spending money in bad ways and they're
saying what's the big deal you know it's
only a little bit but those grains of
seat add up and when when society as a
whole partakes to a certain degree in
Vice this is what you get exactly and
you know Mercy for the criminal is in
many ways violence against the person
who the criminal harmed or or will go on
to harm if you let them be and so it
starts small and it look it's good to be
compassionate we want to have
understanding for people we want to
learn how to correct this Behavior it's
not all about punishment however we have
consistently over the past 50 to 100
years just slowly shifted in the
direction of having a lot of mercy and
understanding towards Those who commit
crimes and absolutely no compassion for
those who are victimized by those people
and that's how you get to this point you
just you chip away at it slowly yeah GK
chesterson said every great every High
Society dies by figure getting uh basic
things and and it's really simple like
you understand that you obviously have
to keep Law and Order that you have to
have families that you have to have
productive Society but every time you
just let one little thing slide you let
one little thing go it can't really be
that bad a little more freedom a little
more Liberation right but you understand
what that thing was holding up you don't
really understand the fence that was
sitting there protecting you from
something and as you continue to
disassemble those things it just you
know you don't even notice you don't
even notice that the frog is boiling
until it's too late it's like property
rights and property crimes if you don't
you know if you don't prosecute property
crimes you end up with your uh retailers
leaving your city which is exactly
what's going on in in uh San Francisco
now uh actually probably going on in
multiple cities I think it's going on in
New York as well there might be shutting
down stores but I know that it's
happening in San Francisco if you don't
protect the rights of the peaceful
law-abiding citizens then they're going
to leave and that's exactly what's
happening in San Francisco right now you
alter time preference right why do I
need to defer gratification here and why
would it make sense for me to if all the
wealth I build up is going to be stolen
Yeah well yeah obviously yeah you've got
people leaving then your tax basically
your your businesses leave which is
happening your tax base leads and then
you end up with Detroit but that's
probably what they want I mean possibly
these things all result in population
decline
well they also result in populations
that are easier to rule right yeah the
population that is obsessed with Vice
and has no uh autonomy has no ability to
take care of themselves is much easier
to enforce your will on and that's a key
aspect of it as well short time
preference as well if you if you have
longer term time preferences to things
like kids and your future what you're
you're paying attention to short time
preferences you're thinking about you
know partying and stuff like that
immediacy of of gratification and stuff
yeah civilization is indistinguishable
from time preference it's yeah the same
thing
so what's your advice to the people in
San Francisco who are on train with a
guy wielding a Cleaver screaming and
then slashing a guy you try to boost his
time preferences
you know like
just gotta set them down have a
conversation with them I know I know
that a drag queen never read a book to
you as a child all right but we're gonna
try to fix that Brokenness now that's
what we're really talking about in the
end you know how can we get more drag
queen story hours for homeless people
that's it that's the only one if only
it'll fix it if only more interested but
not in the way
yeah not in the right direction
unfortunately more men in dresses were
reading to Children yeah that that would
that would fix that would fix everything
talking about drag queens that's
accurate don't get all saying that I'm
transphobic or anything out there
yeah
Where Do We Go From Here I don't know is
this it is all over well no it's not
Donald Trump 2024. look it's not I think
people people got to be able to look
outside of their own culture
civilization it's not the end of the
world it could be the end of America
it's I mean like it looks like it's
almost certainly the end of these cities
but maybe not maybe they bounce back I
can't tell you for sure uh you know
Trump could be the I'm going to arrest
everybody you think so I think Donald
Trump needs to get elected and then we
need to see his new AG just file
criminal subpoenas across the board for
bureaucrats members of Congress local
politicians just go in scoop them all up
lock them in a box
yeah you wonder I like the Box part yeah
where where criminal activity is proven
I'm saying I'm not saying arbitrarily
just arrest people but why not let's do
that no I'm saying like let's do that I
know tyt wants that clip right I'm
saying if a politician was set was
peddling influence to massive
multinational corporations selling out
their local water supply polluting it
and this is something that The Young
Turks are in leftists should be on board
with if there are criminal elements in
government that are selling out the
working class and the people they need
to be criminally charged they need to
stand trial and then get locked up when
proven Beyond A Reasonable Doubt but
isn't it strange isn't it strange that
wanting the same consequences for
political leaders and oligarchs that you
want for the average person makes you an
extremist and the next rule of law to
apply across the board but it's because
the people who are doing these things
and have power own the likes of the New
York Times or the Washington Post and or
Politico and they're going to say oh uh
what did Tim Poole say he's people who
are criminals with power should be
arrested he's far right well and this is
the thing right people talk about
authoritarianism I mean the problem with
with authoritarianism or what we usually
refer to as authoritarianism because
that term has been completely
bastardized is not that there are too
many rules or that Authority is strong
it's that those in a position of
authority do not have the law apply to
them right that's the real issue that
we're talking about people are able to
make rules that they enforce upon other
people that they are not held to
themselves and that's exactly the
situation in the United States of
America today
though I will say of course there are
entire classes of people who don't have
the rules applied to them who are
supposedly lower on the hierarchy in
terms of economic well-being but have a
higher Social credit score because of
neo-maoism can I can I bring some good
news in the organizations that's what it
is right it's a new cultural revolution
these people are not privileged and
therefore they're above you on our new
social hierarchy the whole thing moving
forward go ahead Richard I was gonna say
I want to bring some good news into this
conversation is that okay with you guys
yeah from NBC HSBC downgrades
Anheuser-Busch in Bev as it deals with a
Bud Light crisis that's right their
stock has been downgraded what they're
saying is yeah this could be bad they're
saying that what Anheuser-Busch is
saying about the Bud Light crisis is not
true and it's worse than they're letting
on yeah
I'm not giving Financial advice and
don't do that don't support that this is
moral advice do not support them as a
company so here's what I think they
downgraded the stock to a hold meaning
don't buy don't sell just don't buy it
that sends a signal in my mind with the
with the bad PR and the downgrading
people are gonna sell like crazy because
I gotta pass if I had a million bucks in
Anheuser-Busch or something like that or
tens of thousands of dollars I'd have
sold a long time ago I'd have been like
get me out of here and I'd buy cores uh
that's what I do course is up 20 you
don't want to miss that gravy train but
now they're downgrading it
yo Anheuser bushes is in some trouble
right should have had the foresight to
invest in the other beer stock and a lot
of people get started as soon as it
happened there I bet a lot of people
were like oh we're just shorting Bud
Light again not Financial advice it's a
good idea though I bet there's a lot of
people who just became extremely wealthy
this is what I was talking about this
with stocks right I read the news all
day every day how did we not know to
invest in course you know what I mean
it's like oh wait Anheuser-Busch is
taking a big hit their Rivals are going
to Skyrocket by I'm gonna buy some and
as far as uh Anheuser-Busch goes I mean
now honestly you is not a bad idea to I
mean again not
Financial advice but like you know
shorting Bud Light right now or
Anheuser-Busch right now might make you
some money it helps you know it adds to
the pressure that uh they're
experiencing because you know you get
shorts enough short Sellers and it can
really affect the car the price of stock
so if it's already on the way down I'm
sure there are people that are shorting
it currently I'm not sure it will be the
pressure it is you can find that kind of
stuff on trading View and stuff but what
if in a few months the stock is just
completely wiped out it's a penny stock
yeah because because nobody wants to
hold it because people are like I don't
know man no one's buying it I always
wants to buy this product dude I was
laughing so hard you and I we were
talking about this in a show a little
while how uh Anheuser-Busch had sent a
bunch of complementary cases of Bud
Light to different distributors because
they thought that that would be a way of
apologizing what we said was like no
people actually don't want to be seen
drinking it they're not no one's
concerned with Bud Light as it's too
expensive okay like people don't want to
be seen with the beer and then I saw an
article that was published the other day
I was like ah it backfired turns out
people don't want to be seen with Bud
Light
that's the issue now the viral video
from Fenway where nobody was lining up
to buy like the Bud Light stand was
completely like nobody was shopping the
beer was all there the brand is is
honestly really really damaged because
dudes are gonna look at their buddy and
be like you got the gay one that's what
they're gonna say it's the small little
joke yep and Bud Light does not have a
flavor profile but that demands You by
Bud Light
it don't matter when you buy the Bud
Light and your buddy goes you're gonna
suck a blah blah too or something like
that yeah yeah that's it it's old but
hold on Imagine This
a young college age dude goes to a bar
with his buddies
and he wants to pick up some chicks the
question is right now
um a serious question will they how will
they feel if they're doing it with a Bud
Light
is the chick gonna be alive or he's
gonna be like Oh I'm I'm CIS you just
remember
it's it's such a small thing though
because it's just the oh what if someone
laughs it's all it is that thought right
there will change people's behavior
patterns way faster than than you know
people telling you don't do this any
amount of finger wagging if I grab this
my buddy's gonna laugh at me and
everyone at the bar or at the party in
the social setting is gonna see that I'm
the butt of the joke let me get the let
me get the cores that's it's that simple
and this this is such a beautiful thing
because it shows how much more valuable
memes are and rational arguments
I don't think you're right like like I'm
sorry but feelings care way more than
your facts it's it's just way better in
actually winning a culture War scenario
because here's the beautiful thing about
this Bud Light is Anna Harrison bush is
in this hellacious position because they
because due to the corporate pressure
because they have to please all the
progressives they know they can't back
down but they also know that they've
lost the culture War here they know that
they've now been great did this status
that is an insult to the average
American and so now they're trapped in
this hard place where any attempt to
recover their image will burn them with
their corporate betters with Wall Street
with the investment class but anything
that they do you know to try to recover
that image is just going to Doom them
but they also are just going to continue
to Hemorrhage money if they don't do
something and this exemplifies perfectly
what you were saying earlier about the
fact that the elite have an entirely
different set of morals that they want
to push out of the general public and
often what happens is they overestimate
the degree to which the peons are
willing to buy into their nonsense and
so even though they would say it's good
and it's tolerant and it's wonderful to
celebrate the lgbtq agenda uh of course
your average person doesn't want to and
it's not just a question of whether
they're willing to let other people do
it because by drinking a Bud Light
you're saying I celebrate this
personally and people don't want to do
that yeah you know what I'm I'm sick of
y'all bigots you know what I'm gonna do
you know what I'm gonna do I am going to
produce a Bud Light Pro Bud Light Pro
Dylan Mulvaney YouTube video where we're
going to go around and tell people
please support domovany by drinking a
Bud Light and then I'm going to pay to
run it as a commercial on Facebook and
YouTube to show that Bud Light is the
beer for the LGBT community
you should do it you should see what
happens and then you know I think the
left should agree with that and say
thank you for for this promotion and
then regular people will say I'm not
going anywhere near that beer and what
we're just gonna show honest responses
from people you can get those tops that
go on the top that look like penises
that go right on the cans fit right on
there I'm just saying the last thing
Anheuser-Busch wants is for their is for
Bud Light to be the gay beer but that's
that's what it is I don't know why they
chose that for themselves but it is
seriously they want a new market they
don't want the Frat Boys to be in their
beer and they they got rid of that
market
and hey hey hey here's some advice don't
Anheuser-Busch next time don't break up
with your boyfriend until you have
another one lined up
well and again let's let's not forget
the context in which this was pushed it
was right after a transgenderous shooter
shot up a Christian School killed three
children another transgender shooter was
caught right before they went and shot
up a church and instead of saying we
stand with the Christian Community we
stand with this community that was that
was attacked we stand with this school
we're going to donate to these people
what do they do they doubled and tripled
down on pushing the agenda of the people
who identified it with the same identity
as the shooter that just that just
solidifies that the uh that the the
boycott is the moral thing to do I still
honestly think for the average person
that the you got the gay one is gonna
pay the pay the bills
that's a little too complicated to Phil
what's gonna happen is the guy's gonna
be at a party he's gonna be sitting
there with his jaw hanging open and his
buddy's gonna walk in with a Bud Light
and go you're good yeah that's it that's
it
that's it it's like Beavis and Butthead
but would you but do you ask the average
person why what would you rather have
happen would you rather have the media
and the left say you're a homophobe or
have your your buddy at the bar go
you're gay what is
your sincere more what does the average
person feel more where is your power now
oh boy you got the gay beer yeah
I've already seen that Meme too where
the guy's like drinking it and then yeah
well that's the Babylon beer with that
article it said guys drinking Cosmos
make fun of dude oh that's hilarious
that's hilarious
so easy oh you think my peach Bellini's
funny man this is just that thing's gay
and it sucks bro bro's drinking Cosmos
laugh at friend ordering Bud Light
delicious but you know you know it's
more than that too I think part of it is
that it's just fun to be a part of
something yeah and so when someone comes
in and then they're they're like hey Bud
Light We're not gonna buy that they're
all high-fiving it's not so much that
these people probably care about Bud
Light but that they feel camaraderie
unified around making fun of something
and having a joke and then probably what
happens is the alpha dude is sitting
there and and he's with his buddies like
what do you guys want like I'm gonna
give me a Bud Light like no I'm not
gonna buy that one that's the gay beer
get Yingling and then the other guy goes
oh it is huh I I think yeah you're right
and then once that guy cracks one joke
they all start cracking jokes to try and
fit in and they're just memeifying Bud
Light as as a bad brand it's over like
it's already over it's so over I said
this is actually very very funny it does
really remind me of when people were
shorting uh GameStop because it was it
was a meme but it was also the
destruction of the company
that short in GameStop investing
investing in GameStop when people are
trying to short it that's right because
they were harming investment firms right
yeah good investment for they put a big
investment firm out of business
and also I think uh Trump Jr and
ocasio-cortez even had common ground on
that they both tweeted the same day
about how the government should not be
privileging this investment firm they
lost fair and square yeah I know but
like talking about how Matt Gates and
AOC have worked together on some good
things it's kind of like mentioning that
sometimes Bizarro Superman will like
help someone you know it's bizarre
Superman's still kind of bad oh for sure
I'm not like hold on wait did you excuse
me do you think I'm an AOC Fanboy over
here I'm just saying like no I'm sorry I
want to date her Tim don't you get it
like that's why I criticize her so much
oh I thought it's because you thought
she was evil no no no people only
criticize things that they they like
don't you know that like if you
criticize AOC it's because you want to
date her right if if you have any issue
with like lgbti Lifestyles
that's the iron law of kindergarten
playgrounds that's true exactly I know
you are but what am I pulled or Pig no
when you pull our pigtails because you
want you like her oh that's right yeah
yeah so I really I guess I just really
am so
with AOC I mean so I guess when you make
a video about AOC you're like it's a
marriage proposal essentially basically
I've only I've only made like one or two
videos about her so I guess I propose
her twice I'm waiting you know they're
not getting this is modern times no
one's looking to get married they're
just looking for the Netflix and chill
oh all right you guys ready for this
story here we go from timcast.com gay
conservative Professor under
investigation for offering chocolates to
attendees at an open house I gotta say
hold on hold on there Bertman what kind
of chocolates were they they were
Jeremy's chocolates that's the story a
professor had candy laid out some of
them were Jeremy's chocolates they said
it created a hostile work environment
and put him on leave I gotta say of all
the teachers out there trying to give
candy to children I think this is the
one we need to worry about the least
very good very good yeah Richardson who
was a self-described gay conservative at
the college's Human Resources wrote a
letter regarding the matter which was
delivered by a uniformed police officer
unbelievable to his home on Monday
the state center Community College
District informed Richardson who had
been employed at the college for nearly
33 years that he'd been placed on paid
administrative leave pending an
investigation into unspecified
allegations of creating a hostile work
environment along with reportedly
harassing and discriminating against
colleagues based on gender and we are
not fed up with this yet America oh it's
only getting worse
it's getting so much worse but I'm
wondering what happens to actually make
if people will get fed up at what point
they will if they will because I mean I
am of the opinion that we are in a
cultural revolution in in the United
States
um and I'm not sure how many people here
agree with me that I think everyone does
um and I'm just wondering when the rest
of uh the rest of the
alleged liberals will realize that
progressivism is not liberal that it's
illiberal that it's authoritarian that
it's essentially you know maoism in in
the United States yeah I
his Professor is horrible I'm really a
bad guy
now I want some
you want a little bit yeah
no I'm good
it's not bad
it's really nice I got some already not
not a whole bunch of ingredients in it
either it means it's healthy for you I
guess a lot of sugar all right it's
actually not that bad one bar it's like
19 grams of sugar so I guess if that's
all you eat not the worst thing but
you know we're now in a state where
if you take a dump on a pride flag hate
crime maximum penalty if you try to kill
people on a subway train or threaten to
do so you're the victim of course and if
you're a professor who offers up
chocolate that happens to be made by
Jeremy boring you will be placed on
leave and placed under investigation and
the police will come serve you notice
I mean the left understands the friend
enemy distinction just way better than
the right they understand where they're
at they understand that the key right
now is marking territory knowing who's
on your side they're willing to punish
their enemies and reward their friends
with every opportunity and it's gross
it's difficult in a society we we wish
we wouldn't live that way but we have to
understand that's where we're at right
now and just like you were saying oh you
got to get out of these cities if you're
a conservative or if you're right
leaning or any of this well you also
have to get out of any of these lines of
employment or anything if you are not
along with the progressive agenda
they're gonna come for you no matter
even if you're gay or whatever it
doesn't matter if you disagree with them
on something you will get purged that's
why I like eating the chocolate bars on
the show and making a joke out of it
because I really would prefer it if
people stopped buying Hershey's and
started doing nothing but by Jeremy's
parallel economy Tim actually pays me in
in Jeremy's chocolate that's all he gets
he gets literally all I get one
chocolate bar every night every night
that's it but he has to eat it I and I
have to eat it even if I'm really full
so Tim is feeding the Irish basically
yeah it's true it's true
Starving Artists what's that the bad
joke go ahead
yeah yeah but but this is uh I mean look
this is how the left works though right
so you mentioned earlier someone on the
the subway
threatening people trying to bring them
harm uh the victim yeah they're a victim
exactly well that's because the left of
course divides people up into victim
classes and oppressor classes and I
think a lot of people on the right don't
realize just how far that goes it's
actually ideological consist
ideologically consistent it doesn't map
out of the world but it's consistent
because in their minds if someone is a
victim any and all behaviors that they
engage in are a manifestation of their
victimhood and if someone's an oppressor
any and all behaviors that they exhibit
are a manifestation of their
oppressiveness so even though you had a
clear situation of self-defense right
the person who is screaming at other
people on the subway he's a victim by
his very nature and can never be
anything else because the left's place
them in this category so his behavior
which we all understand is reasonable
people victimizes others actually makes
him the victim and then the person who
acts in self-defense is an aggressor
because he can't be anything but an
aggressor it's literally his nature it's
the label that belongs on him it's his
category it's literal and Narco tyranny
well it's an inversion of aristocracy
right Aristocrats have more privileges
than you they have more rights than you
well because this person is a victim
therefore they are allowed this extra
latitude certain laws don't apply to
them they are above these things because
these allowances have to be made you're
held to a different standard because you
don't have that status
well and I'll also say I mean they
actually these people are so so paranoid
and insane they think and this is they
they honestly think the True Believers
among them that white people on
subconscious level even if they don't
realize it consciously white people are
walking around thinking how can I kill a
black person they really genuinely think
that that is how white people's minds
work in this culture so when a white
person defends himself from a black
person that black person dies well they
were clearly just looking for the
opportunity to kill a black person and
if you want to tell me they don't
actually think that way then give me any
other model of thought that predicts the
outcome of them always insisting that
the white person is an aggressor in
every situation even when it was clearly
self-defense they're projecting these
people feel that way and their
assumption then is everyone else feels
the same way as them
well you remember what Rob and D'Angelo
wrote right about everyone is racist
everything she said about black people
and also in any given situation it's not
a question of whether racism occurred
it's how did racism manifest itself
that's actual Insanity right but that is
what they believe these are their sacred
texts this is their uh academic
literature it's it's it's not whether or
not you have sinned it is how have you
sinned you are you are impure from birth
because of the original sin of racism
racism and this is this it's unfortunate
that these things are actually
explained explaining them is fairly
complex oftentimes and the average
person doesn't understand this stuff and
to try and explain it to them just makes
you sound like you're a little on the
crazy side and
I think that the most effective way to
fight this stuff is to inform people of
what's going on so that way they can see
because when you try to engage most of
the leftist arguments at their face the
leftists don't really care which way you
engage the argument because the point is
to get you to engage the argument in the
way that they frame it right on their
terms yeah and that's part of the that's
that is actually the target it's not
whether or not you say the right thing
there is no right thing to say it's that
you're engaging in the argument that
they make like when they make the
argument about the about you know this
person
um this person that that killed the guy
on on the subway they're making you
engage in the argument in a certain way
and and that's the problem if you can
notice that no this is not about uh
Power Dynamic this is about a guy trying
to protect people and if you can make
that if you can make the viewer of the
art engagement see that and see through
their framing that's some a way to make
people aware of what's going on but to
just engage with the argument that they
present to you that that ends up making
the average person the fool because they
use things like dual meanings with words
you know the meaning that racism will
change and stuff in this in the middle
of the argument and stuff so it's a lot
of modern Bailey stuff but if you don't
know and you approach the arguments on
their face you'll end up losing well you
you have to reframe it because they
refrain things in such an insane way and
what often happens is conservatives and
this is a point that's been made a
million times it's a dead horse but you
know sometimes a dead horse needs a good
smack or two and I've never well that's
that's because it's a Sheamus Coughlin
original but they'll say you know it's
so annoying that leftists will accuse
conservatives of being racist and the
conservative goes to all these links to
explain links to explain if they're not
racist and that's true right and then on
the other hand you have like Fringe
conservatives who think that they're
transcending the Paradigm and going
actually I am arrested what you should
be saying is what are you talking about
exactly this this has nothing to do with
that you're clearly grasping at straws
like don't even engage with the issue of
race when they bring it up when they say
you've never done sincerely when you're
saying when when you're saying oh or
when you're being told you're racist the
the wrong answer is well let me tell you
everyone's race is so yeah did not show
you no that is wrong that is the that is
a failure of of of of you on your part
you have to just you have to say that
you're not racist and that to even
accuse you of racism is absurd um
right off the bat like you're in my
opinion you should you should reply with
an insult because to call someone an
insult or to call someone racism a
racist is to insult him that's the
intent that they're doing from now on
anytime we ever left us on the show the
first thing I ask is
are you racist yeah good move because
then you put him on the defensive well
it's it's because they have to say yes
oh wow we've never you know because all
of us we are not racist so I don't even
know I can't platform you here that's
that's interesting I wonder if the New
York Times will say about you're an
admitted racist yeah so you're a you're
an admitted you admit you're racist
that's interesting it's horrible yeah we
we shouldn't be platforming admitted
racist on the left isn't Robin D'Angelo
an admitted racist yes and this is the
funny thing 100 I would imagine of
leftists who come on the show would be
self-admitted racists yeah guarantee you
know I mean and then we bring on a
conservative and we're like you've been
accused of being racist like I'm not
racist Tucker Carlson been accused he's
like I'm not racist the left they all
will admit it is this the weirdest time
to be alive it's because they're all
white Supremes this is how they feel bad
about it just remember when somebody
says you're racist or asks if you're
racist or asks if you have like negative
racial attitudes what they're doing is
they're looking at you and they're
asking when did you stop beating your
wife if your response to that is well
I've never I would never do that and
hold on why are you even giving us they
just said they made a ridiculous
accusation with no evidence I figured it
out
how conservatives can win every single
court case every single jury here's what
you do right now I hope the law firm
that's representing Daniel Penny hears
me out
ask every juror are you inherently
racist and if they say yes they say to
the judge I don't think an inherent
racist can be an impartial juror on a
race on on on this racial issue anybody
who's moderate or conservative leaning
or independent will say I'm not and any
leftist will say they are jury hack jury
heck and then you're not kicking off
someone based on their political
affiliation or their Washington Pool
they're admittedly racist and you're
like your honor if the person is
admittedly racist how are we going to
have a fair trial yeah we're not is it
bad that's fair point they had outright
said they're biased against people based
on race then you'll get some middle of
the road guy he's about like no I'm not
a racist I think I'll be fairly okay
that's a really good idea yeah and you
can do it any single jury trial any
single one no matter what it is civil
case criminal imagine this imagine
you're trying to win a defamation case
against the New York Times or something
like that when you're doing jury
selection say are you a racist the
leftists remove themselves so here's a
funny story speaking of jury selection
back in the 1980s my dad got selected
for jury duty he was talking about the
people who clearly did not want to be on
jury or did not want to have to do jury
duty so one guy came in wearing an
American flag tie because he's like look
I have a business to run I don't have
time to be on a jury and then this other
lady when they were asking questions
without them knowing anything about the
case they say Do you believe in the
death penalty she goes yes and I think
he should get it
yeah right that's how you that's how you
get off get out of jury duty not the
obvious I don't have time for this or
you dress weird no no you got to just
yeah be a badger but no the guy wore an
American flag tie and they didn't just
answer the questions normally they
didn't call back the jury this is back
in the 80s wow yeah huh that's ingenious
I would love to have jury duty he's also
Cook County right there's Chicago if I
was on jury duty I just I maybe I
shouldn't say this because this will
preclude me for me yeah they're not
you're already off dude there's no way
not guilty no matter what like
been in the crime and then like the guy
being questioned is that you on camera
yes did you commit the crime I did and I
bet okay well I guess then I'll say yes
but like even then you're like I don't
think he pleads guilty and you're like I
don't think he did it what if it's deep
fake if there's if it's like a crime
involving children I probably would like
give me evidence being a reasonable
doubt but if it's something like
possession of a drug it's just never
gonna be it's gonna be a no for me dog
yeah it's just not happening if it's not
a violent crime yeah dude's going home
if there's no victim home if if it's
like
if it's if it's crimes against children
and of a sexual nature or something like
that he's probably I'm probably gonna be
like lock him up yeah like you I need
the evidence obviously you got to print
your case but that's where I'm actually
like the system should imprison these
people then it's like somebody's like he
was caught with he was like driving and
they found a bag of weed in his car I'd
be like I don't see why putting him in
prison is gonna already hit a pedestrian
or something it's like look we have what
is it a nation with us that's not a joke
I'm just kidding is that a real thing
that people if a guy is on trial for
hitting a pedestrian there is a strong
possibility that I'm not going to send
him to prison because you got to think
about what that means are we talking
about a guy who intentionally ran
someone down okay then probably give me
the proof and we'll lock them up
vehicular are you talking about a guy
who's like driving down the road with
his kid and then his kid drops the toy
and then he looks down and someone walks
out from between two cars and he hits
somebody's like oh my God I can't
believe what I've done like do I wanna I
wanna send that guy to prison I would
send the kid to prison for not saying
think about Daniel Penny right they're
saying it's manslaughter they're calling
it manslaughter it was not proportional
bro if I was in the journey I would just
be like there is literally nothing you
can say I wouldn't want to like here's
the problem if they're like answer
truthfully I'll be honest that they're
like do you think you'd be fair and
impartial I do think I'd be fair
absolutely 100 and that's an acquittal
this guy's going home tomorrow I'm gonna
walk in there I'm gonna say to all the
Jerry I'm like I'm gonna be the foreman
all in favor no well I'll tell you this
not guilty and I'm not changing my mind
there's literally nothing you can say
and they'll and then it's either guys
that's my position if you want to go
home you can agree with me otherwise
we'll be here as long as it takes until
it gets until we get a mistrial but I'm
not guilty for me dog
yeah two things the libertarian party
and Libertarians have been very Pro jury
nullification for a long time and you
know if it's if it's a crime without a
victim there's nothing wrong with saying
you know I'm not going to put this
person in jail I'm not going to ruin
their life
um and second of all shame is the
children do yearn for the minds
so oh do you want to send kids to mind I
mean typical libertarian that's where
they're that's where they've been
libertarian what do you mean they play
Minecraft that's the point right they're
here
Minecraft is a Scion
we're using to get them prepared to want
to work in mines yeah this is like a
return to tradition exactly that's right
that's right yeah all right everybody's
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show if you really do
like it tell your friends about it word
of mouth is the most powerful way
podcasts grow especially when they're
trying to censor us and the corporate
press is lying about us and head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member we're going to have an uncensored
members only show live on the front page
of timcast.com at about 10 10 p.m where
we even have members call into the show
to ask questions so if you want to be
part of that click join us at
timcast.com but let's read Raymond g
Stanley Jr says Oren sir you recently
said quote the base cares more about
Trump publicly humiliating journalists
than competent governance do you really
feel that way or was it just a Twitter
tweet thing no I think that's absolutely
right A lot of people have framed the
DeSantis Trump you know uh battle over
well we want DeSantis because he's more
confident and I want to be really clear
I'm a big fan of DeSantis I live in
Florida I love what he's done but I
think Trump is more valuable right now
because I do think that just destroying
the image of the journalist of the media
as something important that crowns our
leaders that holds up public opinion and
defines it is way more important than
any given policy I think it would be
great if Trump was a more competent
governor of course uh or in competent
governance but I do think that at this
point the base does care a lot more
about him humiliating the media and I
think they're right about that
kind of agree yeah it feels good because
they lie they're lying Liars smear
merchants and and he gets a chance to
stand up and say to them for us and it
feels good man yeah the way to break
their their grip on Power and stuff is
mockery that is the best way to make
make fools of them and let everyone see
that they are not better than most of
the time worse than you the only reason
to interact with these Legacy
institutions is to humiliate them and
reduce their ability to Control
credentials is right every single when
the job is finished when every
journalist is looked at like a tobacco
lobbyist that's when the job is done
that's what that's what they deserve and
honestly like we are getting there and
and that's yes that's something I I
think you're right about that in the
sense that look that that's where Trump
is most effective when he's tearing
these people apart and I think many of
their cultural shifts look there's there
are things he did in office that I do
think were very valuable for example the
judges he appointed the fact that Roe is
overturned there's a lot to praise him
for and that but it was the cultural
impact he had and also the fact that he
forced the warhawks into the Democratic
party for the most part just one second
I wanted I want to go ahead and Trigger
some of the uh Trump supporters last
night the worst thing that he did was he
called uh the right to bear arms a
privilege yeah and that is unacceptable
and I want to point that out because I
don't want people to think that like
that slipped by me as like ultimately
Pro 2A guy like I wanna I wanna I wanna
read the Super Chat for you so that one
gamer says LOL why did Phil sound like
SpongeBob
[Music]
SpongeBob singing metal
uh Cody May says teachers are more
competent than that host Phil
was that what reference to
which hosts oh the uh host with uh with
Trump are you talking about oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay uh okay I'm gonna
read this one traveled to the world says
imagine if Bud Light had sponsored a
sequel to Two Girls One Cup the
association will cause people to be
revolted by the beer it's not that
people think Bud Light is gay it's that
they are literally disgusted by the
products listen we are at the rate we're
going on uh if we stay on the same track
we are three Prides away from a from a
two girls one cup float heading right
down Main Street no but I think I think
you're right that was two Prides ago I
think but what trap to the world is
saying is that people see Bud Light and
it reminds them of Don Mulvaney and Del
Mulvaney I describe his nails on a
chalkboard yes so just seeing but like
it's grading it's like oh I just
infuriated by the the whiny shrieking
twitching things that Dylan Mulvaney
does it's like weird nails on a
chalkboard Behavior yeah definitely
disgust is really powerful too it is
radioactive rats is Sheamus you should
make a cartoon where Joe identifies as
one of those tiny chairs so he can get
kids to send it as a lap oh Joe Biden oh
my gosh
come on man well what is a chair uh
they wear the fake chair arms you know
they do that and they'll like the the
it's a couch costume and then you have
like fake arms and you you know you ever
see those no no I've never seen a fake
chair costume yeah there's a bunch of
prank videos like the guys in a car
YouTube the guy the guy's in the
driver's seat wearing a costume that
looks like a car seat and then someone
says I have seen that dude he grabs them
those are great the car looks like it's
dry I got a really good idea for a a bit
that I always wanted to do but it's just
just not there's no point well it's I
don't know the idea was to get a car and
put rabbits in a passenger seat and then
in the in the back seat and then for the
driver have a rabbit taped to your head
and then slowly pull up and then when
you get to the drive-through window just
turn your head very slowly and go hello
I ordered the food please hurry it's
cold up here you know like the rabbits
are taking over I mean they might be I
just think that'd be they have a lot I
mean look the heat the hand that the The
Hand That Rocks the Cradle rules the
world Tim uh I regret to inform you Eve
six has joined the struggle session of
CNN
they're complaining about Anderson
Cooper on the Bird app as well shame on
you Anderson Cooper it's so weird that
the guy from Eve 6 just as like he went
from he's got one of the biggest songs
of Our Generation yeah a couple of them
actually here's to the night I think was
bigger no okay it's not it was it wasn't
well here's it's big but I'm pretty sure
their first the second album was bigger
than their first album I could be wrong
I don't know but uh here's the night was
played at every graduation ceremony and
like school dance that's why like I
think I understand in terms of everyone
knows the song inside out the heart in a
blender song but here's the night
everyone's like oh that's that song I
think if they heard it it might be like
oh yeah yeah he went from that to some
random guy in the crowd just waving his
fist that Donald Trump yeah like why
dude I mean to be fair like they I
didn't the his his star kind of rose
again when he started talking smack on
Twitter because they I didn't really
like he was really out of the public eye
but come on like your star rising in the
sewer is not something that's like you
know and I've offered to have him on the
show like 12 times already and he runs
away every time he's like a dude in the
crowd and he's like yeah Donald Trump
and then I'm like hey bro love your
music would you want to come on the show
and then he runs away he's like okay he
just he's gone he's always been nice and
so I don't want to like I don't want to
talk badly about him but you know it'd
be it'd be cool if uh if he would you
know come on the show and tell us why he
thinks that a MAO a struggle session of
CNN is a good idea I mean he's not gonna
call it that I'm just like hey bro I see
you have opinions would you like to
share them on a on a on a podcast and
then he just shuts up and disappears
come on it's I can hang out he comes in
smack talks and then runs away when I'm
like hello friend would you like to come
on the show I promise I will not never
got a ratio what one of two things I
think I I tweeted if he doesn't come on
the show I'm going to start a band
called Eve seven which is one better
than Eve six should just cover a bunch
of Eve six songs like let's do it yeah
yeah I was rocking out to promise
earlier I tweeted about it because I'm
like I think it's funny like bro I grew
up listening to this music I listened
all the pop-ups we could totally cover
inside out and here's to the night and
put him on YouTube he'd make a bunch of
money it'd be fine because it would just
ruffle his feathers I I gotta say man
the lyrics to promise are really good
like that dude wrote A A it's it's
lyrically brilliant and I think here's
to the night is one of the best songs
ever it's it's a classical it's a
classic Coming of Age like high school
graduation song from our generation and
everyone knows the heart and blender
song and I'm like
bro you're allowed to have these
opinions and you're also allowed to come
on the show and talk about it but I
don't get it it's like he doesn't want
attention well I mean it's because of
the fact that the left thinks that
coming on to this show uh is is
violating the rules you know you're
you're you're engaging with the uh the
verbotan the the people that are not to
be named or spoken about well this is
this part so
he was on and we talked about it Lance
was on the show a little while ago and
then I saw him retweet a day or two
after the shooting the headline about
how the the shooter had shared stuff
from Tim cast I was like dude you were
on the show
you were like on the show with us like
two days ago yeah but he exemplifies
perfectly the cult one he said that I'll
keep it very very family friendly that
engaging in relation a male engaging in
relations with a male of a specific
nature was not gay
and that he also recognized every single
person would disagree with that stance
meaning like he's aware he's this weird
outlier of Fringe belief he's also aware
that on this show I said I think uh he's
like you think Blair White's a men's
room I was like no I think Blair white
should use the the bathroom where she
looks and most fits in and Buck Angel
too so it doesn't it'll probably create
more problems he's like oh that's really
woke and I'm like yeah I guess maybe if
you watched the show you wouldn't call
me right wing but he doesn't watch the
show so he tweets out the right finally
admits that the grooming thing was about
indoctrinating kids into queer culture
into queer Lifestyles and they think
it's sexual and I'm like finally admits
that's like literally the premise of the
whole thing the the the the
trans-pedagogy document shared by James
Lindsay about getting glitter in the
carpet that can never be removed is the
basis of the entire argument the whole
time and they don't watch the show they
have no idea what's being said like
trying to separate children from their
parents and their familial identity so
that they see you as the only person who
cares for them so that they can
inculcate you into a cult of sexual
perversion and have you act in ways
which sexually gratify them if only
there were a word for that if only there
was a word that describes that kind of
behavior I mean I made a sign in
everything so right on anyway that's
right that's right yes don't make me tap
the sign I think we just got to cover
you know promise or something or here's
to the night and then he'll be forced
after the cover gets a billion views
yeah to be like I'm gonna come on the
street let's do it we gotta we got to
get the guy from Eve Sex Max come on we
want you on the show Max we love your
music if you don't come on
remember one song every month by Eve six
until you come on we're gonna make you
double Platinum again whether you like
it or not he has his tweet pinned to his
Twitter where he's like we're gonna be
huge again and I'm like that's easy but
I hope I I hope that he's not thinking
that by just tweeting how he hates Trump
is what's going to make him big because
I genuinely think their music is really
good like he's a really good Lyricist
like the lyric man I gotta tell you and
especially how bad modern lyrics are I'm
like listening to the old Eve six song
I'm like these are good these are well
written so he's just gotta
not pigeonhole himself you know I think
that's what he's doing let's read some
more here where where are we at
fear me it's Bree says hey Tim tomorrow
Maine is having a hearing on a trans
trafficking bill that would make us a
trans tourism state that would allow the
kidnapping and transitioning of children
from other states
ld1735 yikes
man that kind of stuff is really really
really dangerous oh yeah no and it's
only getting worse it's only spreading
to more states which means you're only
going to have more challenges that go up
to Federal it's it's going to get wild
it's gonna get yeah all right Robert
Knight says the the problem with
defaulting is the massive amount of U.S
bonds owned by Banks it'll cause the
Cascade failure leading to the cbdc it's
why Dems refuse to negotiate this is
what I think the plan is maybe so too
and they'll blame it on Republicans yeah
all right Eric Miller says question for
everyone would you surrender your
freedom for for full communist
subjugation if it guaranteed everyone
else's freedom in the country
what
would you choose to singularly live
under a Communist dictatorship but
everyone else in the country all 330
million are guaranteed Freedom Forever
well it wouldn't work there'd be no
Central distribution of goods to me from
who no it means you would be subjugated
you would only be allowed to eat the
bare minimum you would have to do the
work to which you're capable of doing
you would not get fancy cars you would
never have a a beautiful Suite you'd
live in the gutter and it meant everyone
else was free all right I got to talk to
my spiritual director about that one I'm
not sure I think you're obligated to it
Sheamus that's not required to really I
think you are required to why would I
but I don't think so because then I'd be
forcing myself to live in ways that
would destroy my soul but you'd be
sacrificing yourself to save everyone
else maybe wwjd the Jesus of Communism
yeah exactly but like does that save
myself because I'm just like I assume
they're going to prevent me from
practicing my faith right well let me
ask you yes no no I'm not doing but what
if it made everyone else want to
practice the faith if it pushed everyone
else like what if you can let me ask you
this I thought I'll ask my uh you know
when the opportunity comes up I'll have
a long conversation with my spiritual
director about it that's a that's a
moral question I don't have an answer
for here's a question a guy he he's like
ah Sheamus you're you're coming with me
and we're gonna subjugate you and you'll
never be allowed to practice your
religion and you're going to live under
a communist Boot and then you say for
everyone I will choose to do this and if
in doing so everyone else in the in the
world said wow is that what it means to
be a Christian I convert hold on a
second but then in in some sense you
could argue that that's doing good that
evil or that's doing evil that good
might come of it like I'm abandoning my
religion so that other people might
adopt it so I'm doing something really
something good yeah well it's
complicated because it's being forced on
me right but then I'm also agreeing to
have it forced you know what I'm saying
yeah like you you are you no one's
saying you never you don't believe it
it's just you're not allowed to practice
they're like they're gonna lock you in a
box I don't like that everybody else
I don't know that's tough I mean like I
like I said I'll take a question I might
say yes if it was like you win the
culture War right now but I have to live
in a woke University I can't leave
forever I might say yes but whole
there's a different question here where
if it's we win the culture War you know
and all these lives are saved these
children aren't mutilated abortion stops
happening but we kill you or you have to
be miserable or something and I think
there's a much more clear moral answer
to that but if it's you you have to
forego your relationship with God I
think that's you can't practice you're
allowed to believe whatever you want
so like what if they said we're going to
lock you in a university like decently
sized you can never go outside again and
the culture War is Over freedom and
meritocracy wins I might I'd probably
say yes to that you know and then you
can like people will walk behind the
point I'll be in the window and I'll be
like this instead and then it'll be a
plaque on her that's like
he gives our freedom and you're legal
because
you know but there's like video games in
there or something so no no wait what so
you get locked in a building we get to
play video games all day and you're the
savior of the world hey but they're like
the worst woke video games like I always
play depression quests yeah you're
playing like EA's most woke thing it's
unimashable it's just snake it just
makes fun snake all right Lamppost has
question for Phil today marks one year
since we lost Trevor strand he meant a
lot to us in the metal Community I was
wondering if you had ever met or toured
with them and if you had any kind words
to share uh I didn't know Trevor well I
met him um a few times you know passing
by and stuff uh we did one tour they
were on back in like 2012 it was Death
Clock All That Remains uh Black Dahlia
murder and I forget if there was a
fourth band but uh I wasn't close with
them no so I don't have any kind of
special stories or anything uh
unfortunately but I know he was a really
nice guy and he was really really well
loved and uh if you are struggling call
someone uh your life has value and to be
honest with you the people that are in
your lives they kind of share your life
with them so it's not just yours to take
don't don't give up call someone there's
I don't know what the hotline is off off
the top of my head but call The Suicide
Hotline there are people out there that
you can talk to so don't give up cheers
what do we got glucose donors says
Sheamus did you see the Vox video today
about Texas and judge shopping as a
Texan I would love to see debunkers
episode four they made a bunch of claims
and projected the entire time I well
thank you because we're always looking
for new videos to debunk for the
debunkers and we're trying to do one
episode
every month moving forward that's our
goal so if you guys want to see videos
debunked please please please send them
to us my Twitter DMS are open I'll also
mention this make sure you send stuff
that has a lot of statistical
information in it like I I don't want
it's a waste it's a waste of time to do
a debunkers video over something that
we're only refuting based on principle
like I want to look into their stats and
explain to you why their stats are BS so
make sure make sure it's something that
you're watching that you can't figure
out how to debunk that it would take us
research to be able to debunk and we'll
we'll do it Ryan burkebile says a few
years ago a picture went viral of a
black lives matter wiping with the
American flag that was ruled freedom of
speech it's because the American flag is
a national flag and the pride symbol is
not its idea ideology so they're making
the argument that although I do think
it's interesting because you can argue
nationality is protected under the Civil
Rights Act but um I think it's obvious
struggle sessions yeah communism
don't insult their religion they'll come
after you
Greenlee forward yep that's what it is
pinochet's helicopter tour says New York
we read comments from you know Chase
helicopter tours all the time so funny
New York was the only colony to abstain
from signing the Declaration of
Independence of which the second
paragraph is pretty much an instruction
manual
really
wow anybody know that
all right Bo jivan says Tim remember
when you said you drop kick a rapist on
the Philly train now you cold shoulder
the Marine because why you're being a
hypocrite oh but you got out of the my
city yes if I was on the train I would
drop kick the rapist literally raping
the woman that's still true right now I
would not choose to go live in a place
where those things are regularly happen
happening I hope this guy gets acquitted
I'm just saying it's particularly
frustrating to be at a point where
people
after all of these years are still just
blindly supporting these cities living
in these cities and I'm just like when
Kim Potter got arrested I said look
after everything that's happened with
defund the police abolish the police
with the BLM riots you choose to be a
cop and this happens to you like at a
certain point you have to be responsible
for your choices you make that's just my
philosophy that's my moral philosophy
it's like if somebody is in their house
and the house that's on fire it's an
accident we're like okay we're gonna try
and save them if somebody walks into a
burning building it's like do we believe
in personal responsibility and to what
degree so my stance is this the guy did
the right thing he was protecting people
he should not be charged at all but we
all knew it was coming we all knew it
would happen we know the violence has
been on the Subways for a long time we
know the violence is getting worse at
what point does his personal
responsibility kick in that doesn't mean
don't donate to him I'm just saying at
what point are we gonna are we gonna be
like
yeah like these people choose to live
this way you know what I mean
that's that's the point I'm trying to
make
because I don't know man I don't know I
don't want to live that way
all right Sir Thomas Drake says everyone
deserves a legal defense for unjust
prosecution who cares whether he's left
or right he did the right thing my
question to you then would be the people
arrested during the 2020 riots should we
donate to them I mean we're not going to
assume any of them are guilty they're
innocent until proven guilty but
everybody still got mad that Kamala
Harris and the staff for Joe Biden's
campaign were donating to these leftists
uh legal funds they were directly
supporting people we knew were engaging
in these in this violence but on an
individual level we don't know you know
everyone's innocent until proven guilty
when the left rioted during Trump's
inauguration and set fires to the to in
the street and torch the car and smashed
Windows they were acquitted sued the
city and then won millions of dollars
and it was because we couldn't prove
this the the government couldn't prove
any particular individual did anything
wrong
we recognize those people are evil
people right like running around but we
also recognize there's no grounds for
conviction because I don't know who they
are you know I'm just I just
I don't know man
Where's the Line where's the line if if
we assume this guy is conservative it's
okay but if he's antifa or a Democrat
people are going to be like why are you
supporting these people you know you
wouldn't donate to the defense fund of
antifa nobody donated defense fund of
the people with Molotov cocktails after
they were accused of giving those out
uh can experience as I live in Brooklyn
in the only Republican congressional
district in the borough plenty of us do
vote knowing the facts bro well I I uh I
support you man best best of luck in the
fire
you know
all right let's see where are we at with
these years Super Chips
Golden Fleece game says Trump needs to
purge and purify the state
blatant violations of the Constitution
need to be eradicated
I think he needs to arrest people I look
forward to it
you'd be in jail yeah well he didn't do
that so maybe he won't I don't know yeah
neglectful sausages Bill Gates bought
tons of Heineken stock in March shortly
before the Bud Light Fiasco think about
it well you think that Bill Gates was
like and Anheuser you need to sponsor
Dylan Mulvaney trust me really it'll be
great do you do you think that Bill
Gates is really making money off a stock
in in but Anheuser-Busch I mean yeah
well in Heineken I mean I I is is
Heineken moving that much is what what
kind of volatility is in the Heineken
beer market I mean he's he's already
he's already like the owner of IBM he's
got more shares of IBM I can't imagine
yeah oh yeah Microsoft I can't imagine
that that there's
a compelling reason for him to get into
the Heineken business you know why
because AI is just going to start
writing way cooler operating systems
about having nearly the overhead then
people are just gonna have a custom OS
and then Bill Gates will be able to do
anything about it but let me tell you
they won't have custom beers in the same
way you'll see you know not quite as
easy for a computer to spit out a a new
uh glass of beer with a set of tasty
ingredients I'm not a drinker but
Heineken but I can't imagine Heineken
being like the winner look he's assigned
he's a scientist of a sword I trust him
I don't understand John Josh Burke says
Bud Light the beer for the queer
yo yeah well that's not fair because
it's lgbtq it's not just the career it's
it's the lesbian but doesn't the Q stand
for Queen yeah but I'm saying just
saying queer is exclusionary because you
have to include all the letters uh what
does the numbers what does query mean at
this point what are they supposed to
drink queer means an Essence without or
a I think it's an Essence that with
doesn't have a gender is what queer
actually is because the whole point of
queer is to renounce and uh be against
whatever is considered normal right so
to be queer is to reject normal
sexuality so if you reject normal
sexuality you can be queer and that's
what part of the reason why the other
saying isn't all of it like queer it all
fits under queer and that's why you can
become queer and have a have an approved
identity so that's why or that's part of
the reason why the LGBT Lobby has grown
so much because everybody that's a
normal person normally it's normal most
CIS white person that's boring and
doesn't have a politically correct
identity right because if you're a white
person and you're a CIS person you've
got and you're male you've got all the
bad things if you want to get on board
with the approved with the approval
train you go ahead and say that you have
a queer identity and then you're
absolved of your original sin of CIS
what hetero whiteness well this is why
the non-binary thing is picked up
exactly yeah all you have to do is get a
weird haircut and all of a sudden you're
back in the game exactly yeah I mean no
it's true right they've installed all
these expansions which is exactly why
Lance used to be it used to be like you
had to be uh gay and now there's a bunch
of other things you can be there's like
a bunch of expansive packs to LGB like I
used to be LGB yeah
return to tradition
but you get my point where it's just all
these new ways for people to be unique
and that's but that's why the the the
graph that Lance was showing about
left-handed that's why it's all Bs
because it's not that there's an innate
a larger amount of blood that feel
comfortable coming out it's that he
doesn't show you the earlier in it where
it's the same level dips down and keeps
going straight level again fair enough
but so like they start from the bottom
in history and then make and then make
you think that's where it originally was
when in actuality someone responded to
his post with the full chart and it
shows throughout history it's like 10
then there was a period where it dipped
down and then went back to ten percent
yeah but his argument is that it's it's
you know oh people feel comfortable
coming out and Etc it's not that people
are actually members of the lgbtq
community and they feel comfortable
coming out it's that it has become a an
identity that insulates you from
criticism so you have an LGBT identity
you can be you can call on your
victimhood I could argue their positions
better than they could
um why do I think there's a big uptick
in trans kids and all that stuff first I
think social uh contagion plays a huge
role in it yeah but I also think
endocrine disruptors that we've known
about for decades
it's all of our food name a food product
and it's got plastic leaching into it
all of it so you're a mom you're eating
the stuff it's going into your womb into
the baby and the baby is having its
endocrine system disrupted
I have I don't know anything about
endocrine disruptors I heard about them
but I have no idea what they're birth
control is an endocrine disruptor some
birth controls masculinized baby uh baby
girls and then we know that pcbs
phthalates in are leaching into our food
we I remember it was like 20 years ago
they were talking about birth control
leaching into the water supply because
it couldn't be filtered out or something
like that so like now we're seeing a
whole bunch of dudes who are small
effeminate or trans or women who are
trans and I'm like
yeah I mean that it makes sense work
work dumping chemicals in our food yeah
maybe we should consider something like
that like going back to glass
that's what we do look at this look at
this everybody glass bottles rule
you hear that that's a glass bottle and
we reuse them because we are good
stewards of the earth and we don't want
to pollute
all right I'm a Cylon says Elon hired a
member of the world economic Forum to be
the CEO of Twitter he took Twitter away
from the puppets FBI and gave it to the
Puppet Master World economic Forum just
why
it's all part of the plan don't you
understand we're all gonna go live on
Mars it's the only way
why don't you smash the like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends do it head over to
timcast.com become a member because the
members only uncensored show will be
live in about 10 minutes on the front
page of timcast.com you can follow the
show uh at timcast IRL basically
everywhere you can follow me personally
at timcast or do you want to shout
anything out yeah definitely if you want
to go ahead and subscribe to the show
it's on all the major podcast platforms
or in McIntyre show also the YouTube
Rumble Odyssey and all that stuff
Twitter or McIntyre right on my name is
Seamus I make cartoons they're called
Freedom Tunes if you guys want to check
that out we're going to be uploading one
tomorrow and if you like me if you like
what I do if you like the cartoons
become a member at freedomtunes.com
you'll get an extra cartoon each week as
well as extended cartoons and on top of
that you get behind the scenes stuff I
hope you all enjoy it thank you so much
and I love you
I am uh philibonti I'm Phil that remains
on Twitter Phil that remains official on
Instagram the band is All That Remains
available on Spotify Apple music Pandora
the YouTubes go check us out we're heavy
and I am search.com that was a good one
I'm excited for the after show you guys
should become members and you should
join and you can talk to us live all
right everybody we'll see you all over
at timcast.com we got people calling
into the show again we do this Monday
through Thursday it's really really fun
so thanks for being members and we'll
see you all there